there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody
here we are
again don't you guys ever get sick of
looking at us i don't understand that
it's a show
dj maniac says uh did you get a chance
to listen at 11 rocket stones on tail
album my son over yes i listened to it
yesterday i was actually quite rad there
was a couple on there that i didn't care
for i think my favorite one was um
the cover of twist i thought that was
like really cool but that's actually one
of my favorite uh tones on tail songs i
and then i was thinking to myself maybe
i liked that one the best because it
sounded most like the tones on tail
version because some of the other ones
were kind of like wildly
different than the uh
you know than the originals but yeah i
think that was like the coolest one but
yeah they were all like pretty good i
liked all those
uh murder hornet return says tom jenny
that candy i sent was laced with lsd
this should be a fun show i eat it
i i ate it i didn't give any to jenny
you didn't no it wasn't very much it was
just a little uh what it was i didn't
even know there was candy look at what
he's doing he's sneaking around eating
candy behind my back and i didn't even
get anything it was just yeah it was
like and he ate some of my chocolate
bunny from easter too and he had his own
chocolate bunny and ate all that and
then he ate some of mine also yeah
that's what i do
i do that [ __ ] god [ __ ]
he sent some kind of mexican candy bar
it was uh
like uh about the size of a
by the size of the snickers and it had
two of them one on top the other and
they were like long fig newtons but
instead of fig in there they had uh
pineapple okay that's pineapple so
that's good yeah i like it didn't taste
like pineapple i like pineapple it
didn't taste like pineapple though it
actually are you just trying to make me
feel better because you didn't get manny
no
but it tasted like cause it tasted like
um apple
you know like regular apple pie so it
tasted like it was good though yeah yeah
you can send more of those
i'll eat them yeah that would be i'll
give some jetty
no he won't
[Laughter]
he won't even tell me about it mexican
candy tv trigger says i know you guys
likely have something planned already
for the next movie review we don't
actually um not for the sunday movie we
just usually do whatever uh but
blue caprice would be a good follow-up
to this episode yeah there was like a
fictional movie that was made
about this
uh true crime case that we're talking
about yeah i remember when this case
happened and yeah it was called blue
capris because that was the name of the
car that they drove around in
uh i was actually gonna watch the movie
but i didn't have time i watched like a
bunch of documentaries and stuff like
that about it because they did like a
whole bunch of ones and i think that
they had
a what
what she's made a noise she went no
she's done her fighting with a little
what happened we went all blurry oh okay
she's fighting with the toy mice oh okay
i just heard her going is she [ __ ]
yeah
but yeah um what was i gonna say oh and
i thought also
there was a series that's based on this
and i think it's called i sniper
where they interview like the younger
kid the younger guy is not a kid anymore
but um the younger guy
um but i didn't really see that is that
like maybe it's on hbo or something like
that but there was like a bunch of other
you know there was some british crime
shows that had covered it some american
crime shows that used to be on like
investigation discovery or whatever but
like you know there was a bunch of ones
that covered it you guys don't know the
case we're talking about
i guess it's almost 20 years ago now
more than 20 years 2002 yeah yeah so
yeah exactly 20 years ago
had this case where it had this dude
and he stuffs a kid in the back of trump
and they cut a whole little what's
called a loophole
they cut a loophole in the back of the
trunk so he
and they covered it with a little plate
so he could shoot a ar-15 out the back
of the truck and [ __ ] they were
sniping people
to serve a greater purpose so he could
get his kids back it was which is a
weird [ __ ] case
oh yeah this was ran around
ran around it was dc when
well some of them were dc but it was
mostly like the area around dc and
actually they um after they caught them
like they found out that they had
started that spree like a whole lot
earlier yeah and they went all over the
[ __ ] country yeah it was a it was a
trip [ __ ] case
dude is the [ __ ] stone cold [ __ ]
maniac
not well thought out if you ask me but
i mean he kind of thought he was an evil
genius i think he had some military
training the guy he was in the military
for 16 years 16 years yeah
but um because
the technique is good all right that's
like something you'd see in a civil
conflict type situation somewhere in
eastern europe maybe bosnia or chechnya
or some
and uh this probably been used before um
but uh just still not well thought out i
mean it's a high human toll
just to get back at your wife there's
easier ways you know and just well
obviously crazy but yeah the guy was
like uh in that case
i mean he had
he had a lot of problems prior to that i
feel like um and i kind of feel like
that whole situation with his ex-wife
and the kids and everything just made
him snap
so he had a lot of like uh
bigger issues going on yeah he had to
kill all these innocent people to get
your kids back
it's one of those things you see this a
lot in mass shooters yeah this kind of
attitude that because sometimes they'll
be
not fine but they'll be kind of like
just normal or law-abiding prior to that
but they seem to have like a lot of
seething resentment about [ __ ] that you
know about like life kicking him and
stuff like that but it's like look life
kicks everybody yeah um that doesn't
mean that everybody in the world is
against you or something like that they
always seem like they can't just be like
oh bad [ __ ] happens to everybody and
it's like well that sucks but i'll get
through it it's always like he always
needs somebody to blame yeah you know
all he had to do is wait a few years to
get his kids back
[Laughter]
because around 16 17 they start doing
whatever they want to do anyway yeah so
and the stupid thing about that whole
thing i mean we'll get into this later
but the stupid thing about that was that
he probably could have had more
visitation with his kids if he hadn't
like after the case where his wife got
custody of them he kidnapped them yeah
and like took so i'm like well you're
for sure not gonna get him now yeah just
not well thought out something
something's up with him
but we're getting ahead of ourselves
talking about the case i'm just saying
that like you see that a lot with these
type of dudes that are like mass shooter
type things they're they feel like well
the world's gonna pay
for what one or two people did to me or
what i even did to myself you know what
i mean it's like they can't really take
responsibility for that actually it's
always a kind of [ __ ] thing where
they [ __ ] come up with this [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] high
effort high stress [ __ ] mission to
get something [ __ ] simple done it
it's kind of like saying
man it's a whole hell of a lot of work
getting out of work
you know what i mean
you got to do a lot of work to get out
of work you know just [ __ ] it's just
it's kind of self-defeating effort
uh
which always leads me to believe that
that's not what they're after it's
they're using that as an excuse
to [ __ ] kill a bunch of people that's
not i don't think he gave a [ __ ] too
much about the kids
i think it was more about i think
i think he just wanted to feel like
power like he could just pick off people
at random yeah well and some of the
stuff that he communicated to the cops
uh seemed to have
seemed to say something like that where
i kind of feel like he maybe got off on
playing god i choose who lives and who
dies i can just go around and kill
people randomly and
you know they're just going about their
day
doing whatever they're doing and then
suddenly they you know he blows it i
think it was mostly about that
yeah i kind of feel like it was too like
i kind of feel like maybe the whole
thing with the kids like maybe that's
what started like i said maybe that's
what set him off
or maybe like made him crack or whatever
but i think as it went on i feel like he
was starting to like enjoy it enjoy the
feeling of power that it gave him
because he could just go around picking
off like i said random ass people yeah
like he was playing god deciding who
lived and who died you know what i mean
yep and so you know i i guess some
people have that [ __ ]
uh mindset
uh i don't but you know i guess some
people do
i don't get it
uh lion x warrior why does being sober
have to be so dull
[Laughter]
even worse you can't uh drown your
sorrows and forget how lonely one is god
damn it
well it's not all i mean
i don't know i don't i don't really find
being sober boring yeah um
and sometimes drinking a lot like it's
fun but then like the next day i'm like
oh why did i do that it's a job for us
yeah we're usually drinking with people
yeah
usually yeah we'll drink for the show
and sometimes after the show we'll go
you know we'll go to the club or
whatever
uh but you know doing the show is kind
of a social event for us
yeah i mean that's kind of how we think
about it we're just sitting around
having a cocktail hour talking about
talking about [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah or
talking about nothing
hopefully we can uh you know if you're
drowning in your sorrows and loneliness
get the [ __ ] out of the house man
go down to the [ __ ] go to a saloon or
something
go hang out with the other trucks
have fun
tyler says i'm pretty sure most of these
higher purpose manifesto types are just
bullshitting yeah i'm sure they probably
are i think it's part of the fantasy
yeah
yeah i definitely do kind of feel like
they're like they want to think they're
way more important than they actually
take center stage and grabbing the mic
yeah that's what they're doing yeah they
wanted they're like a legend in their
own mind for sure so they have to come
up with all these like really crazy yeah
and some of them couldn't be absolutely
right
like ted kaczynski was right about a lot
of [ __ ]
but [ __ ] bombing people wasn't the
[ __ ]
sitting bombs that wasn't going to make
any difference
yeah i'm not really sure how you get
from one thing to the next thing it's
just kind of like what did you think
that that was going to solve yeah see i
don't think like you said you
implied in your in your statement was
that i don't think they think it's going
to solve anything it's just they want to
do it they just want to do it yeah
kazinsky was bombing [ __ ] because he was
he was foreseeing what is happening now
with like the rise of
big tech nano technology [ __ ]
technocracy uh taking over the world and
uh [ __ ] uh kind of like a one world
type technocracy he's for seeing all
that
ngo stuff human human engine you know
human [ __ ] engineering he wasn't a
dumb ass he was from he was from [ __ ]
harvard you know he was knew what he was
talking about
but there was something wrong with him
you know
bombing heads of corpora heads of
corporate offices and [ __ ] and going
after it wasn't going to stop that
technocracy
that's what i mean i just kind of feel
like look like one dude right is not
gonna be able to like
bring down all of society or nothing
like you're just not gonna be able to do
it it would have been a lot more
effective had he put all this [ __ ] all
his work together into a big old book
and written a book and then gone on tour
and talked about it
seminars and [ __ ] i mean that probably
would have been more it wouldn't have
been that effective but it'd be more
effective than blowing [ __ ] people up
right information but it's just gonna
think you're a [ __ ] loon well where
you are at loon
the unabomber is the whole show in and
of itself did we do a show about the
little bomber i don't think so i kind of
feel like i put it in the poll a couple
of times but it never wins
you guys know you know [ __ ] me coming
from a military background and some of
the best infantry units [ __ ] for me
man [ __ ] there are time for rifles
and pistols and [ __ ] bombs and
[ __ ] track vehicles and [ __ ] there's
a time for all that all right
a lot of that
conventional warfare has a place because
sometimes you have to use it but really
the ultimate [ __ ] warfare this goes
back to operation paperclip and the
german intelligence agencies after world
war ii and cia when all that ship was
forming in the 50s and 60s the ultimate
[ __ ] weapon is information warfare
because information controls the minds
of the friend and foe alike
and warfare doesn't stop until people
believe that they were defeated and that
there's no hope
if you but that and that can only be
done with information and pr and
perception
the way people perceive things that's
why propaganda and [ __ ] control over
media is very [ __ ] important
it's how you keep the [ __ ] rubes in
line that's how you keep the little
people and all the little ants from
rising up
all right
and that's why they're scared they're
constantly scared you listen to them
right now they're panicking and begging
and crying because that's all going away
centralized information
was a thing of the 20th century and even
before 18th and 17th we're heading into
a dem
network society
and everything's democratized now and
the rich people don't like that because
that's where they got that's how they
made their riches they have anything to
do with right and wrong it's just power
there is no truth there is only power
that's that's a good thing that that's a
good way of looking at things you know a
lot of frankfurt school people believe
that and that is true
um so information warfare is [ __ ] the
ultimate
it's because it because it yields mind
control
and really that's all those weapons do
is control people's minds that you
defeat him and afterwards i go okay
that's it the war's over it's kind of
controlling the mind
you know they saw the defeat happen so
now they don't want to fight anymore
well you can do that just with words and
kaczynski could have [ __ ] just
understood that really information
warfare is a lot better than bombing
people a lot more effective john smith
pointed out that he did write a book the
unable manifesto
but he had to go out there and promote
it and [ __ ] be it but he probably
didn't have the ability you know
uh they didn't have youtube back then so
he couldn't be a guest on [ __ ] shows
or anything you had to do it
on foot you know
but if he was so you know if he was so
certain that [ __ ] that technocracy
and the internet was going to take over
and [ __ ] skynet and [ __ ] he should
have just waited until youtube was
invented and [ __ ] kaczynski be out there
and be a [ __ ] number one [ __ ]
guest on all these shows
you know he'd be popular but he didn't
have the character
oh he didn't he wouldn't have the social
character yeah he was crazy so he took
an alternate i mean right being crazy
doesn't preclude people from being uh
popular on youtube or other social media
because it happens all the time but um
you know he couldn't function well in a
society
um he couldn't didn't have any personal
skills
john smith also says the ira used the
trunk sniper technique yeah i thought i
had seen it around somewhere yeah
there's a [ __ ]
civil conflicts in in mount or military
operations urbanized terrain that's
because you got mobile camouflage it's a
mobile
ambush or a vehicle ambush but and it's
camouflaged as a civilian vehicle
because that's what it is
that's the future of everything
everything is camouflaged
ideas are camouflaged armies are
camouflaged they're camouflaged as
corporations
uh you always make a weapon look like
something friendly
you know the days of [ __ ] big red
flags with black [ __ ] swastikas and
hammers and sickles and [ __ ] that's too
obvious about what that is
they'll even camouflage that now
rainbows and [ __ ] unicorns and [ __ ]
you wanted to look harmless harmless
harmless that's way
you want to camouflage everything you
want to camouflage what you believe even
so that's lying deceit
gaslighting
posing as the enemy and speaking sock
puppet accounts [ __ ] bots it's just
that's
that's that's warfare now basically and
it's
it's beautiful what it's doing
you see it working social media you see
it
i see i understand it now
hugo says i like your wig jenny thank
you yeah uh slasher fred says there was
a movie called phone booth that was a
sniper movie interestingly interesting
you bring that up because
phone booth was actually supposed to
come out
right around the time that this dc
sniper attack thing started happening
and they were worried about it so they
actually like pushed the release date
back because they thought it was too
similar lion x warrior says
uh you i just noticed you got 12k
subscribers congratulations yeah thank
you thank you yeah i didn't even [ __ ]
ever i didn't even realize no he took
about the same amount of time that it
took last time like i said we've been
getting because i get a thing every
month from youtube that says how many
new subscribers you got per every month
and it seems like pretty
steady they got us throttled i'm pretty
sure they do
they got us they got an algorithm on us
to keep us growing
at a certain pace i think
um
you know they have select creators that
with corporate backings that grow
artificially [ __ ] huge very quickly
now who knows if those are real
subscribers though on the on those
channels because they don't seem to have
the interaction but
you know
hard to say tyler says i'm imagining
youtuber ted asking people to donate to
his patreon right yeah well i think
[ __ ] i think he'd have been great i
think he'd have been a great uh but he
didn't have the character you need for
to be an entertaining host
you know what i mean but he probably
would have been a pretty interesting
guest on a lot of [ __ ] um
conspiracy theory type programs
which i wouldn't say it was a theory a
conspiracy theory it happened a lot of
the stuff ted kuzninski was talking
about
he was just talking about the
growing civilization that would [ __ ]
be bad you know what i mean kind of
anti-democratic kind of autocratic
technocracy which has been brewing for
[ __ ] centuries really
the industrial revolution well the thing
is that even if you're right about some
things that doesn't mean you're not a
[ __ ] nut case though exactly but the
thing is is he was a nut case but he was
smart he was he was in yeah like i said
that doesn't mean those two things are
not mutually right right you can be
smart
and be be [ __ ] dangerous and and
[ __ ] and he was kind of cantankerous
we're talking about another kid it's
okay yeah
he was he was evidently not pleasant to
be around so i don't think he would have
[ __ ] made a very good youtube guest
uh not with his attitude he was just
kind of he didn't take a shower was
dirty you know and
look and he was kind of bum he's like a
bomb living out in the [ __ ] shacks
and [ __ ]
living off the
grid yep murder hornet return says the
guy who shot reagan is selling out music
shows now is he really yeah
i haven't followed that guys i thought
that i thought that dude was dead no
he's out oh okay he was crazy well yeah
he's clearly they eventually released
his ass
yeah because [ __ ] that was a long time
ago wasn't it
1980 yeah he did that to impress judy
foster yeah little did he know jodie
foster's a lesbian well and like
like why would you even think that
anyway even if she was just like oh boy
yeah you shot a president for me yeah he
was trying to get her attention
i love you
dude's got some weird ways of thinking
about [ __ ]
that's crazy that's [ __ ] weird well
he probably thought that you know he you
know reagan was a republican he probably
figured that [ __ ] jody foster was a
democrat and [ __ ] maybe jody foster
the democrats at the time were talking
about how bad reagan was so if he shoots
reagan he's a hero in jody foster's eyes
i got him for you
you know crazy they're funny yeah that's
very crazy yeah i mean come on you're a
little [ __ ] nuanced dude
uh i'd love to see soraya interview ted
right yeah that would be funny
i like soraya master
he's real good host he's a real good
host
got a good voice too
that kind of stuff
yeah john smith says so his bombing
campaign was the ultimate guerrilla
marketing for his book yeah yeah
but it didn't it didn't yield it didn't
work really it didn't stop the
technology it didn't didn't [ __ ]
really make didn't cause his book to
sell
and he ended up being a pariah it's
he was trying to he could have only won
his war
in in using information warfare and
bombing somebody is not information
warfare
he should have become a master of
information warfare you should have just
been what is that noise
that's weird what
sounds like static i think it's my maybe
it's my speaker over there yeah that has
been like making oh you know what it is
oh that [ __ ] noise-making machine i
thought that was off that's all maybe
maybe you maybe you hit it or something
yeah i didn't touch it i have a white
noise machine up there and it was like
making some kind of i thought pookie was
trying to like get out of the room or
something like that like scratching on
the door
um
he should have been uh doing things to
kind of like exposing them and
everything but like i said he would have
needed the internet and it really wasn't
around
at that point
the early internet i guess was
when they caught him he just
he plays and he didn't have electricity
in his shack anyway so he couldn't use
the internet
yeah you know i mean
what did he do
he was crazy
yeah and as i said that's kind of what
you know when we went off on that
tangent i was like one of the things is
that yeah they can have all these
grandiose ideas and [ __ ] like that but
in the end they just want to blow up
innocent people yeah to make their dick
hard or like make him feel powerful
that's really all it comes down to he
was delusional yeah i mean you can come
up with all the [ __ ] uh you know post
hoc [ __ ] reasoning you want yeah but
i mean you enjoy it you want to blow up
people you get off on it
you know all the other [ __ ] is just i
think justification well i think i think
kaczynski kind of saw himself as kind of
like the guy
from um v from vendetta he's a guy
living in nature
fighting people who are
capitalists who are destroying the earth
and uh you know that that kind of stuff
uh and bringing in a [ __ ] high-tech
[ __ ] totalitarian kind of a
regime
and and he's out there fighting the good
fight that's what he thought but he's he
was delusional
yeah yeah
leon x warrior says uh i agree with tom
about the algorithm shenanigans because
like i said around christmas time you
guys have a type of cult status with my
kids generation really they all are
familiar with you guys which is
hilarious because we're old as [ __ ]
we're almost [ __ ] we don't know
anything that we have kids and
kids listening to us for [ __ ] which
is very strange but christmas time why
christmas time well he said he's just
saying that's when he said that
uh back around christmas time well yeah
that's the funny thing and it's like and
the well the weird thing about it is
like i i subscribe to channels of people
with like of all different ages like
just depending on what the interest is
like if they review cool like books i
like or movies i like or they talk about
horror [ __ ] or whatever um then i'll
watch them i don't really think about
how old they are so maybe i don't maybe
i don't know like maybe kids will like
that too but the thing about it though
is that even a lot of channels
that i'm really into that
to me like seem really popular because
they get like a lot of
uh comments and stuff
they have about the same
uh number of subscribers as we have or
sometimes less
like actually some channels i really
like only have like five or six thousand
which
i don't know what that says but
i like
i like a bunch of different channels i
listen to for different reasons
i like midnight's edge a lot really good
uh the gathering i like that channel
um i like tim pool
i like uh we are change
uh i like uh which are kind of like
independent reporters they'll actually
go on location and do stuff uh flekas
flekas talks i think is what name is
reflective speaks that [ __ ] is
funny as [ __ ]
um he just talks to protesters and he
interviews him [ __ ] nice and he just
lets them say what they want to say
that's hilarious
um i like uh there's a bunch of i like
um myth vision which is that's mythicism
i have guests on
dr price will be on they'll have all
kind they had a guy i was on today or
yesterday i think was today talking
about manichaeism and uh i didn't really
know much about the manichaeans they're
really good it was like a mixed eats
east versus west
mixed down in [ __ ] persian greece
during you know third century and it's a
lot like it's probably where they got
the idea of [ __ ] the jedi and [ __ ]
the force and everything because they
kind of believed in the same it was a
fusion of christianity
zoroastrianism and buddhism and taoism
from china it's all happening there
really good show you guys should watch
that
um uh
and i was like man i must be a
manichaean but uh
so i like a lot of different kinds of
shows you know what i mean that are kind
of independent i don't like uh corporate
type stuff you know
um
[ __ ] uh
reuben report pretty good
um [ __ ] a little uh what's his name
little
guy who did dear reader
little gay guy little gay russian guy
he's [ __ ] really good genius he had
genius work on on north korea one of the
only persons in the west that truly
understands north korea because i was on
the dmz [ __ ]
uh in korea and [ __ ] used to get used
to see north koreans [ __ ] those camp
graves
my old camp is now a museum
for a dmz museum
the the garpost collier which i did in
mission at garbo's car was actually
demolished i watched him do it video of
it they blew it up they blew it up the
goddamn it they blew it up
[Laughter]
they blew up my guard post
it was just made out of [ __ ] solid
concrete [ __ ]
rebar reinforced it was nuclear hardened
[ __ ]
guard post
it's weird tyler says i've been watching
you guys for a few years i'm 20 and
started at about 16 or so oh no [ __ ]
yeah see i never would have known you
don't have any idea yeah i just assumed
because of like all the [ __ ] that we
talk about yeah and because of all the
tangents we go off on we're like
remember back in the day in the 80s yeah
we assume it was all over so i just
assumed it was like people the same age
as me yeah
yeah
i know that's dumb to assume that but
it's just kind of like i don't know so
because even you know some of you guys
that like make comments about certain
movies and stuff like that like from the
70s or whatever i just assume you're my
age but maybe not yeah because like i
said a lot of uh channels that i watch
that are horror movies and horror books
and stuff like that they're all into
like old [ __ ] so yeah
you know
you can never tell when when we were
your age we were listening to people too
[ __ ] i used to just [ __ ]
trip out [ __ ] dialing in with old fm
radio try and am radios trying to listen
to [ __ ] art bell
and man his shows
they're now starting to put them up on
youtube with that and
not taking them down i don't know why
they used to take them down but they're
up there now coast to coast a.m
well because probably whoever owned the
copyright was like get that off of there
yeah it's not they're not
tripping about it now because they used
to do that with the unsolved mysteries
because people used to upload the
unsolved mystery shows and they used to
always take them down because of the
copyright but now they put them up
legally like on 2b and stuff so all of
our bell shows were recorded they're all
recorded they're out there it's just
that they kept taking them off of
[ __ ] youtube
i've listened to them recently they're
listening to a bit of them they're still
[ __ ] real comforting to listen to
the topics are real passe by today's
standards but man when you were
listening to him back in the day in the
early internet age or even the
pre-internet age
um you weren't really quite it was
society was a little more of a low
information society you weren't really
you really weren't really aware of what
was true or not you were constantly
trying to figure out what was actually
true
and he'd come up with some weird [ __ ]
like a star child skull and you could
really kind of only imagine it and then
eventually the internet came out and you
could [ __ ] look at it and go oh
that's what he's talking about
um
and um art was a [ __ ] master
entertainer it didn't matter how
ridiculous his guest was he took that
guest seriously and he made that guest
feel [ __ ] honored to be on the show
you know what i'm talking about
yeah the guy would [ __ ] be taught is
saying some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] art you
don't say and but actually with for
something about art he would give the
[ __ ] topic an air of
well because he didn't come out and say
you're full of [ __ ] yeah he never did
that
no he was always at least entertain the
possibility even though it already was
contradicting with everything else you
know it would contradict with everything
else we knew would be true it was just
they were fun shows to listen to like
dudes will show up saying that in the in
their backyard they have a hole that
goes all the way down to hell for some
reason i remember that one like more
than anything that was that that went in
the elevator to mars elevator to bars
yeah it's [ __ ] a hole because i'm
listening to that and the guy's like
totally serious i'm like dude dude yeah
elevator to mars somebody needs to put
that dude said he had a hole in the
backyard and he [ __ ] and he didn't
know how far how far down it went and he
was trying to measure it he never could
[ __ ] figure out how deep it was he
was throwing things down in it
eventually he put a microphone down
there and [ __ ] when he pulled up they
played the recording and it's a bunch of
people screaming like in hell it was
[ __ ] great
absolutely great you're listening to it
[ __ ]
back in the [ __ ] early night back in
the 90s i guess it was mid 90s maybe 93
or something
might have been 95 now it might have
been later i can't
i think it might have been around 96.
you're listening to it going goddamn
that's some spooky [ __ ] imagine if you
did have a hole
that went down
to [ __ ]
hell you know
and then the mueller sky car they talked
about the mueller sky car for years it
turned out mueller was [ __ ]
embezzling all the money and [ __ ]
cheating everybody the the thing those
things never really it flew a little bit
but
now these [ __ ] little drones can fly
you can do that [ __ ] easily they have a
thing like the mueller sky car now i'm
looking at the four props on it if they
want a hundred thousand for it but it's
all just electric powered
well that's the thing i mean everybody
just kind of wanted [ __ ] that was like
mysterious and creepy yeah there's
another era
it was fun though
yeah
[ __ ] had that dude show up talking
about sidonia on mars
i forgot that dude's name yeah we did a
show about that a while back yeah was it
hoagland hogan yeah richard c holden
and he would just go on with these
[ __ ] hokey ass [ __ ]
satellite photos of mars
saying if you look here you can see that
this and he's describing it as if it's
buildings and [ __ ] cities and [ __ ]
but no that's not what it was
now they have [ __ ] landers and hd
[ __ ] down there just just hills
it was cool though
your imagination would run wild with you
yeah maybe there was cities there
millions of years ago
i'm not that imaginative
i was i'm like hey shut up you don't
understand
[Laughter]
the photos weren't quite clear enough
yeah
you know what i mean to where you they
weren't they weren't so clear that you
could deny it you'd be like yeah maybe
maybe that maybe that is a ruin you know
wouldn't that be neat
but that was the fun of those shows
you know that was the fun of them
rebecca says back with coffee and
crumpets with butter and vegemite i'll
be awake proper soon yeah it's uh it's
morning there that's bro it's breakfast
time yeah everybody's talking about
coastal which is crazy how great coast
coast john smith said i remember the
face on mars being a big thing in other
circles for a while yeah yeah yeah it
still is i kind of i mean you know the
the circles of of nutters is getting
smaller and smaller like at least
concerning that issue but then they move
over to another issue they move over to
the next [ __ ] thing yeah but um yeah
the clearer the pictures get they're
just kind of like oh i guess it's not a
face after all what other wacky [ __ ] can
i believe in that they move over yeah
to something else yeah four throw down
said turned out space is quite boring
exactly exactly i hate to say but it is
kind of boring
no it's not boring i mean it's not
boring but it's just there's not like
all the fantastical [ __ ] that people
there's some [ __ ] there's some [ __ ]
going on on [ __ ] venus right now
there's uh some gases in the
upper
atmosphere of venus that
might indicate that there's life there
in the in the upper atmosphere of venus
that's some weird [ __ ] but more time
about microbial life
well yeah because there's a band inside
the venus's second upper atmosphere that
has earth-like temperatures and almost
earth-like [ __ ]
you know it's an earth-type atmosphere
and temperatures and pressures
where something where
a microbe could live in it blowing
around
in there
and the question and and there's some
gases that
may mean that there's some kind of uh
microbes
because the gas remember what gas it was
that particular gas is [ __ ] uh
associated with microbial [ __ ]
basically waste waste gases
that's some big [ __ ] but here's the
thing let's say you find
microbial life in the upper atmosphere
of venus
chances are you take a dna sample of it
as prior earth life
because
material has been traded
through all these planets over millions
of years they're contaminating each
other
so i mean there's a chance you might be
able to find some life on mars
and it's from earth
deep down underneath the soil
because meteors trade
each other back and forth
all right so are we ready to actually
get to the topic now or what let's get
to it okay
so
we got okay so what i'm gonna do
i got a little summary at first like if
you don't know anything about the case
and then what i'm going to do even
though
there were like some murders and crimes
prior to
you know the main event if you want to
call it that
but i kind of want to go into it from
like the dc sniper attacks proper
which happened in october of 2002
and then go through that because they
didn't know who it was at that time
and then after they caught them
um then i kind of want to go back and
talk about
them like as individuals and also about
all the other [ __ ] that they did prior
that they found out about after word
okay so that was kind of like the the
order that i had it in it seemed like a
lot of the documentaries i watched had
it in that kind of order and that's just
like the order that sort of made sense
to me because i was going to do like a
timeline like
all this kind of stuff but then i was
kind of like eh
i'll do it this way because i kind of
feel like they kind of came onto the
you know onto the scene like with the dc
sniper attacks all right so uh in case
you don't know a little bit of a summary
as i said this happened in october of
2002
uh usually called dc sniper attacks or
the beltway sniper attacks
um these were a bunch of uh as
advertised a bunch of just random sniper
attacks on random civilians
over a three-week period
in the washington dc area also
surrounding area maryland and virginia
during this particular uh phase uh there
were 10 people killed
three others wounded
uh along interstate uh 95 in virginia
and along the you know baltimore
washington metropolitan area
uh so there ended up being two shooters
one of them a 41 year old man named john
alan muhammad one of them a 17 year old
boy named lee boyd malvo
uh and they got caught like later on now
when they caught them they found out
that they had actually started their
spree like way back in february of 2002
and that there were at least seven other
deaths attributed to them prior to the
[ __ ] that happened in dc we'll get into
that a little bit
um i don't know if we want to spoil the
ending but um they caught the guys uh
yeah they caught them yeah um and uh
john allen muhammad was actually uh
sentenced to death and he was actually
executed in 2009.
uh malvo is was a juvenile when they
caught him uh but he got like uh six
life sentences yeah he's not going
anywhere and he's uh still in there like
he's trying to like appeal some [ __ ] but
uh he's still in there he was down to
the influence of an older guy
yeah we'll get into that we'll get into
that come on man you know murder is
wrong
and um
although
people change a lot over time
i'm not going to say that the guy
couldn't be paroled maybe but
maybe middle age and when he's too old
to like do anybody when he's outside
when he's outside the [ __ ] danger
zone maybe middle age and
maybe they can make him a [ __ ]
trustee or something let him out or
something uh
it did happen when you could say he was
almost kind of like a victim of a cult
in a certain way
it did seem a little bit and i'm not
excusing him um it did seem a little bit
like that it almost seemed a little bit
like he was kind of groomed kind of
brainwashed a little bit and brainwashed
a little bit um he was probably old
enough to to know better but in some
ways he was kind of vulnerable also you
can do that to an adult you can [ __ ]
get an adult [ __ ] fired up to do
[ __ ] illegal [ __ ] go out and kill
people yeah it depends on the person and
well it depends on the person and it
depends on your interaction with them
and it depends on you know their
personality what and kind of like if
you're able to
kind of get to their weaknesses and
stuff like that so i'm not saying
i'm not saying that he shouldn't be
punished i'm just saying that
maybe if he had been left to his own
devices
he might not have done this [ __ ] on his
own no i wouldn't have i don't think he
would have because he seemed like a
fairly normal kid pretty regular for for
for where he came from but so this is
kind of the same kind of thing that we
bring up whenever it's like serial
killer couples and stuff like that
there's usually not always but there's
usually one that's like way more gung-ho
and then the other one like kind of
talks them into some [ __ ] you know and i
kind of feel like that was a situation
here now even though when they first
caught him
when he was still 17 uh he was all still
under the influence and he was you know
talking about how awesome it was and
[ __ ] like that but
recently
um
you know everybody that knows him or
like people that have interviewed him in
prison and stuff like that said he's
like a completely total yeah change yeah
they said he's like he's like apologized
to all the victims he said i was a
monster back then it's definitely good
so so he seems to have gotten away from
it like 20 years later but
i don't know i don't really know how i
feel about it like i said
he was a kid
but
17 is old enough to know better
so i'm like really i'm really on the
fence about some people don't develop
they aren't aren't very well developed
yeah and like i said he didn't have you
know he had but he was a very vulnerable
person myself at 17 i was pretty
advanced and i was still dumb
yeah i was dumb at 17.
most people are dumb at 17. that's why
i'm willing to like give him a little
bit of leeway because
you know even though what he did was
[ __ ] horrifying and i would never
excuse it
but he was a kid
well he's pushing almost 40 now
yeah i thought yeah yeah it's about time
to let him out probably
uh yeah i don't know i mean
they could let him out just like just
[ __ ] keeping him keeping
[ __ ] eye on him holy [ __ ]
well what to see what it is i mean look
he was 17 under the influence of a
[ __ ] evil man
and uh yeah he was [ __ ] up
he did he did time
there maybe there's something where he
you know they might be able to put him
in some kind of weird halfway house for
a while and see how he goes let's see
how he does and then if he [ __ ] up
again yeah because i'm real
i don't know i'm real iffy about
we've done shows about like child
killers and stuff like that and i'm not
even talking about 17 year olds because
that's almost an adult but i'm talking
about like [ __ ] 10 and 12 year old
kids yeah and
some of those people like did [ __ ] that
was so [ __ ] evil that it's like i'm
not really sure but then the thing about
it is like they're a kid it's like i
kind of think about what i was like when
i was 12 or 17 or whatever i didn't kill
anybody obviously but
you know you do dumb [ __ ] and like when
you're an adult like when you're almost
50
you're kind of like a completely
different person yeah i could barely
relate to some of the things that i
believed in you know when i was 17.
right
it was like with somebody else
a lot of the stuff like you know grampus
is on here he knew me at that age i was
still the same person
but you're dumb man at 17.
yeah like i said you're not operating
with a [ __ ] full information at that
time well your brain's not really done
cooking until like you're in your
mid-twenties
at least and then you don't you don't
have enough life experience to
understand you can't put things in
perspective
you know
yeah everything's like the world's
biggest deal yeah
and i remember that like i remember
feeling like i don't feel like that
anymore but i remember feeling like that
like when you were a teenager everything
was the end of the [ __ ] world you
know like everything was like this big
[ __ ] drama like you thought like if a
bad thing happened it's like nothing's
ever gonna be
good ever again it was just like that
and like almost all teenagers are like
that that's why i [ __ ] old dylan and
[ __ ] what's his name from the [ __ ]
from the [ __ ] school shooting where
was that the columbine columbine shoot
yeah that's that's what mode they were
in everything was a big [ __ ] deal
had they [ __ ] just graduated two or
three years later they had forgotten all
about [ __ ] high school they'd been in
the club
yeah and we talked about that when we
did the columbine show because i was
just kind of like all they had to do
like i understand like i don't
understand what they did because i'm not
going to shoot up at school for christ's
sake but even and i wouldn't have done
it back then either they thought
everybody was after them and they were
getting ven
right and that's see that's another
thing and that's kind of like the same
mindset that i'm talking about here
where it's people that can't deal with
just the regular vicissitudes of life i
mean bad [ __ ] happens to everybody
everybody gets [ __ ] over everybody
it's nobody's fault necessarily
um you know sometimes it is
because you're too [ __ ] sensitive
well it could be that too but well the
thing about it too is that sometimes
it's just circumstances it's not because
somebody has like is out to get you i
mean sometimes it is but it's like
i kind of feel like people that have
this type of mindset that think like the
whole world's against them or
everyone's picking on them it's like i'm
not saying that that doesn't happen like
because sometimes you know the columbine
kids might have been bullied or
something like that but it's like the
whole world
isn't out to get you it's just like you
know it's maybe one [ __ ] or a
handful of [ __ ] and it's like
those people are not really important in
the grand scheme of things so you just i
know it's hard but you just can't like
let that get to you to a point where
you're just gonna ruin your entire life
to get back at them and you're really
not getting back at anybody
i mean in in the long term and that's
again this is just like if the you know
the dc snipers if
you know if john muhammad if his
ultimate goal or his whatever he thought
he was doing was hey i'm gonna get back
in my ex-wife i'm like that's not what
you're doing though you're not taking
revenge on her by killing a bunch of i
think he wanted to like want to just
cover it up so like if he killed he was
gonna kill her and then make it look
like random and he would get away with
it but like i said that seems like a
really stupid way of going about it
you're not getting revenge on the world
it's like you're just a little person
just like everybody else nobody really
cares that much about you so
you know what i mean it's like please
get over yourself i kind of feel like
it's this really really weird
it's like this really weird everybody's
picking on me but that's also kind of
like a weird kind of narcissism because
you think that everybody gives a [ __ ]
what you're up to or like gives a [ __ ]
what you're doing and i guarantee you
that hardly anybody does so
you know what i mean so you're not like
getting getting revenge on anybody
you're not owning anybody you're not
doing anything like that like you think
you're doing you're just
being a dick for like no
no reason
okay so let's do the timeline
of the dc area sniper attacks and then i
like i said then we'll go back in time
and like talk about the the earlier [ __ ]
that they did that they found out about
later
so the first thing that happened
uh wednesday october 2nd 2002
about 5 20 uh in the afternoon
there was shot fired through a window of
a michael's craft store
and this was in aspen hill in the sort
of dc area
uh which i think it's like a suburb
outside of dc i'm not i've been to dc
but i'm not real familiar with all the
suburbs around there
now so somebody shot in the window
now the bullet didn't hit anybody
thankfully uh it went right by this uh a
woman that worked there a cashier named
anne chapman
but that was pretty much as far as it
went like so nobody got injured that
particular time
so the cops came and [ __ ] like that but
you know nobody got hurt and said they
were just kind of like oh maybe it was
an accident somebody's getting off blah
blah blah didn't really like make a big
deal about it
but
about an hour after that 6 30 p.m
there was a 55 year old man named james
martin who was a program analyst
and he was coming out of a grocery store
a shoppers food warehouse which is in
wheaton and he was walking to his car
like in the parking lot and a shot kind
of came out of nowhere and it got him
like right in the chest
and he was killed pretty much
immediately one of the documentaries
that i saw like had the all the 911
calls of like the people calling in for
so like a woman that was in the parking
lot too like she saw him fall down and
had heard the gunshot and she was like
ducking behind her car with her little
she had like a little five-year-old kid
and she was calling being they're like
hey are they bleeding he's just like
yeah i don't know i'm behind the [ __ ]
car jesus christ just get here but yeah
so there was that
so then the next day uh thursday october
3rd
um
four people shot in the morning and then
one shot in the evening so five people
uh dead on october third
now
the first one
happened at 7 41 am
this was a thank you
this was a 39 year old
man named james l buchanan uh better
known as sunny that was his nickname he
was a landscaper
uh and he was shot dead near rockville
maryland he was actually mowing the lawn
uh at a business that was like part of
his job you know and somebody just came
along and shot him and again the 911
call like his neighbor called and at
first he thought because this was you
know dc is kind of like a sort of higher
crime area but like the suburbs around
dc are actually like really low crime uh
because they tend to be like a little
bit more affluent so
nobody
i mean i read somewhere that these the
dc sniper attacks in this county or
whatever
just those made the crime rate go up
like 30 or something like that just from
that because there's like they we have
like maybe a couple murders a year
and all of a sudden we have like five in
one day type of thing
so nobody thought the dude had been shot
like the the his neighbor called and
said i think his
what did he say he said i think his
lawnmower exploded because all he saw
was the dude laying down the lawnmower
running and then there was blood
everywhere so he just thought he didn't
think the dude had been shot but yeah so
they got there and found out but uh he
was dead at the scene
8 12 a.m
there was a 54 year old man uh prem
walekar prem kumar wilekar he was a taxi
crab taxi cab driver
uh he was also killed in aspen hill in
montgomery county while pumping gas into
his taxi at a mobile station uh and
you had to watch because gas stations
were uh kind of a target like a bunch of
people were killed while they were
pumping gas let me say something real
quick what's that
um i'm trying to see who it was i said
it
um john says that columbine guys weren't
bullied one was suicidal under the
influence of a psychopath yeah we did uh
a show on on them already
and i mentioned it in the show
that
when i was living in past christian
mississippi my first wife
we
a couple that were friends of ours he
owned a comic book store
uh that was on in long beach mississippi
um
he went he graduated from columbine high
school he had graduated from that high
school about
five or six years before the shooting
happened
and he gave me a lot of background on
the way that that school was that
the teachers and that community and
everything was what i was going to call
say that they were very class conscious
in a negative way
okay
they were new money
they didn't like outsiders and they
liked very conventional people
that those two guys kind of came from a
click of kind of like prototype goth
type
industrial kids and just kind of misfits
and um
that they were kind of i wouldn't say
they were bullied in the physical way
but they were kind of
people looked down their noses at them
like they were unusual they didn't like
them and evidently a lot of a lot of the
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] that happened with
those kids didn't come from the students
but some of it was from the teachers
and then the teachers backing up the
students
there's a big thing about the white hats
and the jocks and [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] with them and so it was
like class warfare nobody said that they
were bullied
it's just that um
they weren't bullied in a conventional
way it's just they were being slighted
a lot
and uh
they just was gonna strike back they
hated that school and the people in that
school other than their friends
am i saying it's right no it's not right
but we don't live in a world of right
and wrong we live in a world of [ __ ]
people doing whatever it is the [ __ ]
they want to do
you know
um and people get hurt
i mean
my high school was similar yeah in that
it was kind of upper middle class kids
right the teachers were fine but um you
know if you weren't like a blonde
cheerleader type or a jock or something
like that you did kind of yeah you got
picked on a lot right what was weird
about if you were poor harris and
klebold is that
they weren't poor their parents were of
same class as everybody else it's just
that they didn't [ __ ] like upper
middle class american culture
they liked [ __ ]
subcultures
you know they liked cam fdm and some of
the industrial stuff they would have
been hanging out in the club with us all
right that's
we have a lot of people like that you
know or that's that same thing you know
they're upper middle class but you
wouldn't know it
they're just like their own thing
they don't like they're swimming against
the current you know
especially back in those days today it's
very different uh the [ __ ] american
society is a lot more open than it was
back in the 90s
okay
so i'm not justifying what they did just
you have to know the background
the well it's always better to
understand
but understanding something is not
excusing it
i mean
these p i i'd [ __ ] walk around
past christian in mississippi this you
wouldn't know me from adam wouldn't know
the [ __ ] you know my family was from
mississippi for [ __ ] generations and
[ __ ]
and they would look at me sideways
because i didn't dress like them
you know what i mean yeah that too but i
could put them in their place
because you know i knew the culture
so
i understand it just you don't got a
ship of school you know you're in
[ __ ] school you know what i mean
the game changes once you're out of
school it's just that they weren't
they didn't have any older mentors i
think
that they would listen to you know so i
said in that show back then had they
known me i'd have straightened them
[ __ ] right up i'd straighten them
[ __ ] up
i said look just chill
don't [ __ ] be [ __ ] crazy
because they wouldn't listen to adults
outside their little [ __ ] scene
tyler says uh can he realistically get
paroled if we talk about malvo
oh no that was six life sentences
probably not but well that he has been
doing like appeals because they did
overturn a couple things because there
was a law passed in virginia
that uh said you couldn't like give
somebody a life i can't remember like
what the um
exact thing was but it's like somebody
that committed crimes before they were
17 or before they were uh when they were
still a minor like you couldn't give
them a life sentence or there was some
kind of thing but the thing about it is
that they committed crimes in a whole
bunch of different states
so it wouldn't really matter yeah so it
wouldn't really matter if like one law
was overturned or one sentence was
overturned because there's still like a
bunch of other states that he committed
crimes yes that makes it a lot harder so
i don't think that i don't know i mean
you know he's young still i don't know
if it's it might be feasible when he's
like an old man but his
best prospects for him at the age he is
in now and the legal status of being
across
having [ __ ] homicides in several
states depending what the department of
corrections is like in the state that
he's in
sometimes there are special programs
where
they have like class a style statewide
trustees
where a person they'll take a guy like
that who's a special case
um
because it happened when they were young
and it was a big case and this and this
happened you know and there's some hey
you know he was kind of young when that
happened these other people kind of made
him do it it's a famous case he's well
known
sometimes they can do something like uh
release him almost kind of like as a
[ __ ] ward of the state
where he sleeps
uh at a [ __ ] jail
a local jailer he has a room at a
certain state facility
and he's something like a janitor or
um working at a police station [ __ ]
on cars there's all kinds of stuff that
they can do
they got guys with life sentences that
do that kind of stuff where they're not
in a prison
but they work for the state and they
can't really leave state facilities
that's that's one thing that certain
states do that
so it's like a real high-level trustee
but usually the guys that do that have
life sentences
they kind of grew up in prison
they don't really get that shot until
they're in their 40s
because they got nowhere to go they
can't run
where are they gonna go
they can't survive as this [ __ ]
civilian
they
they take care of them you know what i
mean [ __ ] they feed them clothe them
house them they can't get a job they
don't have an identity you know we're
gonna apply for a job they don't have a
[ __ ] id card you know
if they were to run they'd be
re-apprehended in months
you know a year or so
but that's a lot of those guys won't run
because then they lose all those
privileges you know
but they'll probably do something like
that for them eventually
all right so going back to october 3rd
as i said uh we've already had two
people killed on october 3rd uh the
third victim happened at 8 37 am this is
a 34 year old woman named sarah ramos
she was a housekeeper
and she was killed outside of the
leisure world shopping center in norbeck
she had actually just gotten off a bus
and was sitting on a bench reading a
book waiting for another bus or waiting
for a ride and somebody just came along
and shot her in the head
9 58 am
another woman named lorianne louis
rivera she was 25
killed while vacuuming vacuuming out her
minivan
at a shell station somebody just came
along and shot her
so those were the four that happened in
the morning
then the same day 9 20 p.m
uh there was another shooting pascal
charlotte who was 72 years old he was a
retired carpenter and he was just uh
walking down the street and somebody
came along and shot him uh he died about
an hour later
now
what they determined as i said the first
shooting they were just kind of like
i mean they did have like some of the
investigators on like in some of the
documentaries i was watching and they
were just kind of like when they had the
first shooting happen or the one that
happened in the parking lot
they were just kind of like yeah maybe
that's just random or maybe somebody was
just targeting that dude but they still
kind of had a feeling that it's like
this seems like it's probably not good
um you know what i mean they were kind
of waiting for something else to happen
you know what i mean uh but it wasn't
really until october 3rd that they
realized that there was somebody just
going around like targeting people uh
they didn't know if it was random at
first they thought maybe there was some
kind of
pattern or some kind of something they
were looking for something
um but in each of the shootings the
victims were always killed by a single
bullet uh fired from some distance away
and interestingly nobody saw
anything like they didn't know
at the time that they were shooting that
there was a two-man team that were
shooting from a car that had been
modified in what they called a
quote-unquote rolling sniper's nest they
didn't know that at the time so they
were kind of like well these people
hiding in the bushes or they you know
they they thought maybe they were in a
car but
they did actually figure out at this
point they're like well maybe they are
in a car so which means there's probably
two of them you know what i mean because
it's like these
this isn't just like a drive-by
these are like very very
tactical like everybody was hit in the
chest or the head like with one shot
so it so there was that
now
obviously um everybody like the public
started to flip out at this point as you
would because they didn't as i said they
knew that there was somebody going
around targeting people but at this
point they're like look this is like all
over the map it's men it's women it's
old people it's young people it's all
it's white people it's black it's indian
it's like it's all different races so it
didn't look like anybody was
targeting anyone specifically they were
just kind of like going around like
taking whatever opportunity presented
itself which obviously is terrifying
because that means
you that could be anybody you know what
i mean you could just be like hanging
out doing whatever and somebody just
like walks by and shoots you and that's
essentially what happened to all of
these people
so at this point they have a um they
kind of have a thing like the guy that
was sort of at least in montgomery
county
uh the chief of police charles uh moose
he kind of like took over the whole
thing and you know they we're kind of
talking about maybe closing the schools
and [ __ ] like that but they're like we
keep the schools open but they had to
like they wouldn't let the kids go
outside like they had to kept the shades
down [ __ ] like that and then uh after
there was another shooting at the gas
station so it was like they started
putting tarps like so people could pump
gas without people seeing them like
driving by [ __ ] like that
now uh interestingly there were a couple
of kind of like sort of false leads at
this point as i said they didn't really
have much evidence to go by they didn't
really have any witnesses nobody saw and
much of anything nobody they didn't find
any shell casings or anything like that
until later
now they did actually have a witness
that said oh i saw um
like a white panel truck after one of
the murders
um but this turned out to kind of be a
false lead now interestingly one witness
did say that they'd seen a blue chevy
caprice which uh spoiler alert was the
car that the snipers were driving um
but
that was kind of like that worked out
that
they stopped the car a couple times but
blah blah but they were kind of like
focusing on the white panel truck
because a couple other witnesses
reported that i don't know why that
happened but yeah
um they did figure out that the murders
were all carried out with a 223 caliber
rifle
now at this point
uh the snipers started going farther
afield uh you know at this point it was
kind of like dc and just like the
surrounding suburbs
but
now they're kind of going farther out
and there's like a couple of days in
between the shootings
so october 4th
a woman named caroline seawell she was
43
and she was actually in the parking lot
of a michael's store a different one in
spotsylvania in virginia and she was
putting her stuff in the back of her car
and somebody came and shot her in the
chest now she actually did survive
but she didn't see you know anybody
obviously now because
this was the second shooting that had
happened in a michael's uh
parking lot because remember the first
one where nobody got hurt where somebody
just shot in the window that was also a
michael's
so
for a second they thought well maybe
it's like a disgruntled michael's
employee you know what i mean because at
that point that was like the only link
they had to go on because it just seemed
like everything was so random
um so they thought it was weird that it
was like two michaels but it turned out
like not to have anything to do with
that but they were just kind of
clutching at straws at this point
october 7th
at 809 in the morning a 13 year old boy
named iran brown
uh his aunt had just dropped him off at
school
and i guess what had happened was that
he got in trouble on the bus and so he
had gotten kicked off the bus like for a
week or something so she had to like
drive him to school but she had to drop
him off early because she had to go to
work so she dropped him off
and
at least in the documentary they show
her like driving away from the school
and she's listening to the radio and the
radio is talking about the sniper case
because obviously that was like all they
were talking about
and then she heard a gunshot and she
turned around and her nephew was like
laying on the [ __ ] grass like he'd
been shot 13 year old kid
now she was a nurse thankfully so she
like [ __ ] backed the car up and put
him in the car and took him to the
hospital and caught even called the
hospital ahead and said everything so
they they did actually save him
amazingly uh even though he was shot in
the chest like he was all [ __ ] up but
he did live
so there was that like because the thing
about it was that the round that they
were using
it's one of those ones that's like
really it's
it's fast and so like it goes in and
leaves like a little bitty hole and then
yeah it [ __ ] up all your [ __ ] it's like
a big huge exit once you tell more but
i'm going to tell you guys a little bit
more about this
i'll give you guys some a little bit
more of a [ __ ] background to what's
going on they're using an ar-15
if i remember correctly and if the dates
are right it was probably a 20-inch
barrel ar-15 i don't remember the exact
brand they had a lot of different brands
out uh you know civilian version of kind
of like the m16a2 it's what they were
using for memory serves
five six [ __ ] is a
cartridge about that long if you can see
me on video um
the case is about big around as a nine
millimeter pistol cartridge long it's
neck down to 22.
it's fast out of a long barrel it's
[ __ ] nearly i think it's three
thousand two hundred feet per second
yeah coming out of them out of the
muzzle that's what they said on the
documentary okay the the idea was is
that you can zero it
for 100 meters
and be able to shoot
out to 300 meters and hit a man in the
chest
without any sight adjustments that way a
soldier can just
point and shoot and hit
so that's what the velocity is all about
there's no time for bullet drop
point of impact goes up and down a
little bit but it's only a matter of
inches
it can reach out to 700 meters but by
that time the bullets slowed down quite
a bit it's not as lethal
most combat
happens closer than 150 meters in in the
military all right
so 300 is 300 meters that's a long shot
up close it's a very small bullet moving
fast it
and uh it's hard okay
um
up close it's moving fast enough to
fragment if it hits a person so if
you're using it indoors it's almost like
a hollow point it'll hit and
explode uh especially if it's the
lighter versions like the 193 dm193
round which is what we use in the
vietnam i think there's a 45 grams or 55
grains something like that i don't
remember the exact bullet weight you get
all these numbers kind of go through
your head
later on they were using a steel core
version of it to give you a little bit
of armor penetration it was heavier
um it didn't fragment quite as well at
long distances or is it up close
at long distances it didn't you know
when you talk about 150 and beyond it
wasn't fragmenting anyway
just make a 22 cut of a hole
like an ice pick
but it had a lot of energy if it hit
bone it would fragment that bone and
that bone will blow up like a little
grenade inside you
cause a lot of what's called secondary
wound tracks
so
jenny says he got hit in the chest and
he lived amazingly
not really a lot of guys have survived
that round especially at range up close
is a lot harder you know what i mean
zero to 20 meters zero to 25 meters
indoor type ranges that really that that
[ __ ] round will cut you to shreds
because it's just a lot of energy in a
little bitty bullet when it hits
anything it just kind of wants to blow
up you know
well i'm just saying amazingly because
most of the other victims a couple of
them were were hit in the head and a
couple of them like it blew half their
head off yeah even even from you know
900 feet or something like that but most
of them were hit in the chest
and they were dead before they hit the
ground like it's like a little bitty
uh you know entrance wound but the exit
wound was just kind of like i mean they
had they were interviewing a cop at one
of the scenes
yeah he's just kind of like yeah i never
saw nothing like that before okay well
there's some things that are happening
shot placement is always paramount it's
critical
i remember back in the 80s man i was
reading the rags this is [ __ ]
pre-internet 80s and 90s we would do
what was called reading the rags
and for you youngsters what that meant
was reading magazines
and we had all these [ __ ] gun
magazines
and they had a thing that was going on
which was the fbi one shot stop
statistics they were trying to figure
out what was the best pistol cartridges
for law enforcement not only the
cartridges but the particular rounds
which ones were the most effective
in
percentiles you know what i mean and the
one that was really winning was
three to seven magnum 125 grain jacketed
hollow point it was it was clocking in
at like 93 percent
one shot stop in instant capacitation
rates
so dudes were flocking to that round
another rounds and they're looking at
nine millimeter and 25 and boy we were
all in these [ __ ] hollow points and
man in those days i would just thought
that hollow point was just the most
scientific thing
ever you know
and um
because they had all this data and all
this science and [ __ ]
wound ballistics and gelatin tests and
everything you still see all this [ __ ]
on youtube
they're making ballistic gel and
shooting into them and [ __ ] what
would that you know how effective would
that be
i was a big believer in hollow point
man but you know
as time went on we started i started to
realize it was a scam
what always it what always
the main [ __ ] cause of [ __ ]
lethality is penetration it penetrates
through you
that's it okay
what causes the one shot stop
or instant capacitation is shot
placement
because really when you look at all this
[ __ ]
anything that instantly incapacitates
you pretty much would have incapacitated
you no matter what you were hit with
things that didn't incapacitate you
wouldn't have incapacitated you no
matter what you were hit with
it wouldn't have mattered
the reason why
357 magnum was [ __ ] doing so well in
those tests is because everybody who was
reading those magazines were trained
[ __ ] law enforcement people
they were running to that cartridge
because the magazines were telling them
that was the most effective ones so they
were running to that one well those
dudes were better shots the placement
was better that's why it was 97 percent
or 96 percent you know i'm talking about
92.
it was the shot placement that's what
was skewing all those percentiles
that's why i didn't bother [ __ ]
hollow points anymore let's go full
metal jacket it's all shot placement
that's all what was the same with these
rifle rounds
it's head shots headshots are always
effective especially with five five six
it's a [ __ ] armored little [ __ ]
capsule the high velocity bullet goes in
there it's pressurized now
and that pressure is all [ __ ]
contained inside that skull and it blows
out the back if it wasn't pressurized
through the bone the wound wouldn't look
like that
because the pressure wouldn't be as high
but any all head shots pretty much are
[ __ ]
instant incapacitation and death you
rarely survive it
unless it's something very low energy
like 22 long rifle out of a pistol
or 25 acp out of a short barrel pistol
there's not much energy there
take 22 long rifle shoot it out of a 16
inch barrel there's a more energy
there's a more effective head shot
now just because i said this for you
guys who know what i'm talking about
that doesn't mean you go out and buy a
32 acp
power energy is still energy and you've
got to do the penetration has to happen
you want 9 millimeter 40 37 magnum
you know the cartridges that everybody
that are using
three or seven sig i'm not really sure
that's worth it
and anything that's a rifle round is bad
news all rifle rounds are bad news
five five six that's using that of a
seven out of a [ __ ] m16 or seven six
two thirty nine i have an ak those are
small rifle cartridges they're still bad
you don't want to get hit with that
all right and a full-size rifle round
doesn't kill you any more
than a small rifle round death is an
absolute you can't be any more dead than
dead you know what i'm talking about
you just need enough to kill you
and a small rifle round is enough to
kill you
more is almost
wasted
so
that's
that was to the gun guys they know what
i'm talking about
so the 13 year old kid yeah he was shot
in the chest but he did live um and he
uh recovered and he actually um ended up
testifying at the trial later on so
there was that
now interestingly at this point uh
there's actually documentary footage of
the chief of police charles moose um he
had been upset about the [ __ ] before
obviously because you know his ass is on
the line because he can't uh catch these
[ __ ] um
but
once a kid got shot because he was 13
years old uh he was up there and he was
like tears like running down his face
and he was just kind of like just kind
of like just [ __ ] up before but it's
like now it's personal uh you know
shooting a [ __ ] kid this is [ __ ] up
he didn't say that but like that's kind
of like what he was getting at
so uh he kind of wanted to pull out all
the stops at this point so they did
they really wanted to find some
connection some clue some something
because it at all the crime scenes
because you know people have been sniped
from a long distance and from a moving
vehicle
um you know which they suspected but
they weren't sure
they didn't really find
all that much evidence at the scene
obviously and obviously there was no
connection to any of the victims so they
didn't really have anywhere to start you
know random crimes are the most
difficult ones to solve obviously
so uh so they did this kind of like this
big sweep and they started they did like
that shoulder to shoulder we're just
we're combing through all the [ __ ]
grass and we're just doing all this kind
of [ __ ] and they did actually end up
finding a shell casing and
they found like this little spot where
it looked like you know the you know
they had they brought in their own
snipers and it's like where would you
go if you were gonna snipe somebody at
this location and they started looking
there and they did find like a little
place where it looked like the grass was
kind of padded down
and when they were looking around they
found
a tarot card
the death card obviously because they
had to be on the nose yeah and this
tarot card was written on it
was
call me god okay on the front
and then on the back
it said for you mr police
code call me god and do not release to
the press that's what he said he's edge
lord yeah big lord
now
the cops told the media please don't
like release this information but of
course um it leaked somehow so they
actually were made public the next day
by a tv station locally and then the
washington post uh ran the [ __ ]
so there was that
october 9th 8 18 pm
a man named dean harold meyers who was a
civil engineer he was 53 years old
he was shot dead while pumping gas at a
seneca gas station near manassas in
prince william county virginia now again
people were like freaking out and on
some of the documentaries people said
when this was going on because this is
only like a few days you know what i
mean this isn't like like a few days
span and people are just getting picked
off in a you know a similar kind of area
and they're like people would be like
they put gap be putting gas in their
cars like bobbin and weaving you know
like nobody wanted to stand still when
they were outside like people would be
like coming out of a store and they'd be
like [ __ ] sprinting to their car
and they didn't you know nobody wanted
to like stand stand still anywhere
because they were afraid you'd get shot
and it wasn't like a crazy fear because
that actually did happen
so yeah this guy's just like pumping gas
and he was shot
october 11th at 9 30 a.m uh another like
a businessman named kenneth bridges who
was 53. uh also pumping gas at an exxon
station near fredericksburg uh it's
spotsylvania county virginia um yeah he
was shot also he was 53 years old
october 14th 9 15 pm there was a woman
named linda franklin she was 47. she was
actually an fbi intelligence analyst
who lived in arlington county virginia
she was in a parking lot in home depot
with her husband they had just come out
of home depot they bought like some
shelves or something
and they were in the parking lot putting
the [ __ ] into their
the back of their uh suv or whatever
and
the husband like went around to the
passenger side and she was just down
there and like the
the sniper like just blew the back of
her [ __ ] just blew the side of her
head off
he said later that he was actually going
to shoot the husband but then when the
husband moved he said oh well and then
shot her instead so yeah
um yeah so at this point as i mentioned
earlier gas stations started putting
like tarps up
you know so people could pump gas and
like nobody going by the street could
see them
uh so then there was a a lull of five
days
then on october 19th at 8 00 pm
jeffrey hopper who was 37 he was walking
out of a ponderosa steakhouse with his
wife
uh in ashland virginia
and he got shot in i believe in the
abdomen
now his wife um called for an ambulance
and he actually did survive like i said
he was [ __ ] up also but uh yeah he
survived now when the authorities were
searching around this particular scene
in the woods not too far from the
restaurant they found a letter that was
like in a ziploc bag
and this letter demanded 10 million
dollars
and basically said something like uh
your children aren't safe
so
yeah it was kind of like a ransom but it
didn't really have any details to it i
think it was just kind of like a terror
type of tactic
now interestingly because as i said
there had been all these tips about a
white van or like a white panel truck so
i kind of feel like the cops were sort
of like focusing on that and i can't
blame the cops because like i said these
are a bunch of random victims and it's
like there's really not any clues so
they're just like kind of jumping on any
[ __ ] lead they can get on
so
at this point like october 21st
they arrest two guys who had a white van
who were outside of a gas station i
don't know if they were doing anything
suspicious or if it was just like
happened that they were just in the
wrong place at the wrong time
but they got arrested
uh it turned out that they were not the
shooters but they were undocumented uh
immigrants
so they actually had
they got cavity searched and then they
got turned over to what was then the ins
and they eventually got deported but
they were not the shooters
the day after that october 22nd
there was a bus driver who was 35 his
name was conrad johnson and he was
actually shot almost six in the morning
he was standing on the steps of his bus
this was in aspen hill maryland
and uh at this point
moose the um the chief of police charles
moos
he released um
kind of a little bit of one of the
letters that they had gotten from the
shooter your children are not safe
anywhere at any time
so the bus driver he was alive at the
scene but they took him to the am to the
hospital and he died later
now no shootings happened on october
23rd
but um at this point the they had their
ballistics experts that actually did
confirm
uh conrad johnson as the tenth fatality
uh in the beltway shootings like all
from the same gun uh they were all sure
they were sure of that at that uh at
that point
and uh they found like when they were
searching one particular place they
found a tree stump that they thought um
that the shooters had used uh for target
practice so they were able to get a
little bit of
evidence there
so
basically okay so at this point
obviously this is on the news like
[ __ ] 24 7 in the area america's most
wanted came out and did like a whole
show because at this point the dudes are
still at large and they're trying to
like figure out who the [ __ ] uh it is
and as i mentioned everybody
yeah understandably we're like freaking
out nobody wanted to be outside ever
some schools closed uh they wouldn't let
him it's like everything was cancelled
it's like everything was just kind of
like they closed everything up because
you never knew you could just be like
walking down the [ __ ] street or
walking through a parking lot and
somebody could just like blow your
[ __ ] hat off which is [ __ ] crazy
so uh as somebody mentioned earlier the
joel schumacher film phone booth which
was also about a sniper
was actually supposed to be released
around the time that this started
happening but it was pushed until spring
of the following year because everyone
was like flipping out about it like i
said
so
okay so the main point guy on this at
first was charles moos as i mentioned
who was the uh chief of police in
montgomery county but then because some
[ __ ] had happened like over state lines
obviously they're gonna bring in the fbi
and atf and secret service and all that
kind of stuff to kind of like coordinate
they had everybody working on this like
[ __ ] 24 7 because they really really
wanted to like [ __ ] catch these
[ __ ]
um
now it took until i guess it was like
october 4th october 5th um
they've linked like a lot of the crimes
together so like i said they did
determine that these were all like the
same person
they set up some hotlines to get tips uh
which
you know can be good but they said we
got like way more [ __ ] tips i think
like the woman on there said
they got like a hundred thousand phone
calls and it's just like there's no way
so like i'm sure most of them were
probably like [ __ ] cranks
and
again like a lot of the tips talked
about like a white panel truck or a
white box truck type of thing with dark
lettering on it and a couple of them had
said well we saw this like white truck
or white van that was like speeding away
from leisure world where one of the
people was shot
um and there were two guys inside it
and so at that point they're just like
pulling over every [ __ ] white van
that they can [ __ ] find and obviously
that's not what the people you know
ended up that's not what snipers ended
up driving so there was that
now as i mentioned uh the shooters did
actually try to they left like the tarot
card and they left that letter asking
for the 10 million dollars
interestingly
um
yeah the tarot card was left at the one
but also
they tried to call the police too a few
times
and the weird thing about it is that
i think because they were getting so
many tips and because it was such chaos
like around this investigation
the couple times
that john muhammad called the cops and
he was trying to like prove that it was
really him that it wasn't just a crank
and so he kept telling them
look into this other case like this
other crime which was like in montgomery
montgomery alabama
and they did look into that crime but it
didn't seem to have any connection
to it wasn't the same mo in other words
so they were like well this guy just
must be full of [ __ ] or you know it so
it seemed like he tried to call a few
times and it just for whatever reason it
just kind of like kept slipping through
the cracks even though it actually was
really him now after they caught him or
like later on in one of his letters he
actually said oh the last five people i
shot that's like on you because
i asked to communicate with you and you
like blew me off essentially so he was
like trying to blame the cops for i was
trying to talk to you and you wouldn't
talk to me so there's that kind of thing
now one of the calls they did actually
end up tracing it
uh that he made like they said okay
maybe this is the guy so they trace it
and it was a pay phone at a gas station
in uh henrico county virginia
now when they got to the phone though
there was nobody there
although again there was a guy there
like in a van and so they those people
got like arrested or detained but it
wasn't them
so yeah
so as i said he yeah he talked about
something that happened in alabama
so uh
so they looked into that so i'll get
into that later because there were like
a [ __ ] ton of other crimes they
committed before this [ __ ] even happened
now interestingly this is about when
they got like a [ __ ] break in the
case october 17th
now they found a footprint um
behind or a fingerprint rather
benjamin tasker middle school which was
where uh iran brown the 13 year old kid
was shot
and there was a letter in a ziploc bag
like pinned to a tree or something like
behind the thing behind the school
so they were actually able to pull
a fingerprint and i believe some dna
like off of the uh off of the bag
now
they matched that fingerprint
to
uh malvo one of the shooters the 17 year
old
and interestingly they were able to
match that with a fingerprint
from a robbery like a liquor store
robbery in montgomery alabama
now
the thing about it though is that his uh
his fingerprints were on record see i
heard two different things
wikipedia says that his fingerprints
were on record because he'd been
arrested he had a prior arrest in
washington
but some of the other sources i read
said well his fingerprints were on
record because he was um an immigrant
from jamaica
like he came there with to the us with
his mom
so it could be so it could be either
thing but um yeah so his fingerprints
were on file
so at that point they had malvo's name
like they knew who he was they didn't
know where he was but they knew who he
was
now
because they had some tips once they
figured out that malvo was
you know it was his fingerprint
then they got some tips where people
that knew him or knew about what's going
on and said oh
uh if it's a two-man team then you need
to look into
john allen muhammad because that guy
it's almost like a weird like father-son
type situation they have going on and
they're thick as thieves and if
malvo's involved then john allen
muhammad or john alan muhammad is almost
certainly involved as well like if it's
two guys so that's how they found him
like that one fingerprint
now uh they also got
at one point one of john muhammad's army
buddies who actually lived in washington
state
they had you know they had served
together and like i said i'll get into
their history like a little bit
but they'd serve together and this
friend
as soon as he saw the news coverage and
saw like the type of gun that was used
and like the way that went about it and
where in the area it was
and he's like i bet that that's john
muhammad and he said he called the cops
and said well
i think the reason that he's shooting up
all these in this particular area
is because that's where his ex-wife
lives like that's the area where his
ex-wife lives at
and even then like even his buddy like
his army buddy knew
he i think he's targeting her but like
around
the outside or around the fringes or to
make it look like
i think he wanted to kill her but he was
trying to make it look random
you know at least that's what they
thought later on
so
they also found out that there had been
a car
that muhammad had bought in new jersey
the chevy caprice
now they found the license plate at that
and uh once they figured out what the
license plate of that car was that he
had bought
they realized that they had actually
checked this car because every time
there was a shooting obviously they put
up you know like a roadblock
and went through like all the cars and
[ __ ] like that and this car the capris
had actually been stopped a few times
but they didn't find anything
in there
um and it wasn't connected to any
criminal activity so they just kind of
like let it go so
it had been on their radar they just
didn't know like i said i'm not blaming
the cops in this situation because
this kind of [ __ ] is like really really
difficult to solve they weren't
targeting anybody in particular they're
just driving all over the place just
shooting random ass people
um the car had also actually been
stopped for a
uh minor traffic thing
uh two hours before one of the victims
was shot two he had got the car around
mayhem
yeah that's essentially what imagine
what a city would be like if you had six
or seven of these guys doing this six or
seven don't encourage anybody no i'm
just saying that's
the way
certain things are going on like [ __ ]
bosnia and [ __ ]
that and a bunch of other [ __ ] layered
on it at the same time
this is a military operation this dude
has a military back background he
he knows he knows what he's doing he's
creating mayhem
but um
that's just one of imagine if there's a
bunch of
well yeah you'd over you'd overwhelm law
enforcement you'd overwhelm the system
people would just be like uh
hunkered up in the house [ __ ] just
going damn you know well they kind of
did that in this situation yeah right
yeah very stressful
yeah and like i said i i was watching a
couple documentaries about it on youtube
and like there was some people in the
comments that had lived in that area at
the time and they could remember what it
was like yeah and he's not even a
trained sniper
you know i knew train snipers i was in a
recon platoon you know if i can
i was in one of the [ __ ] recon squads
first 227 recon he'd take it a
sharpshooter metal i think not me
no him yeah yeah i don't know i'm an
expert
expert which is way above sharpshooter
but i grew up shooting heart the army
shooting courses were [ __ ] easy all
right the only course that would have
been challenging for me would have been
us army sniper school
but i didn't go
i didn't get the chance but that that's
a challenging course
tyler says have you guys seen the batman
yet this vaguely reminds me of something
in that movie no we still we still have
it it'll be on it'll be on uh i mean i
wanted to see the batman i wanted to see
the north man i wanted to see x we gotta
see endorsement yeah
i mean
we just haven't been we're still paying
for that [ __ ] movie theater thing
it's just like we never go
well we've been hit by from we've been
hit so many times by [ __ ] bills and
[ __ ] scares and [ __ ] about new roofs
and this and that we've been [ __ ]
holed up and yeah but i mean at least
going to the movie that we're we already
paid for that so you know what i mean i
mean you never told me to [ __ ] pile
up and get in the car i would have
driven down there so well i was good
well i was gonna go see i was gonna go
see x but by the time we got around to
it it wasn't playing anymore okay i
think the north man is still playing
yeah players you know i'll sit there
i'll i'll sit in there and forget all
about it yeah i know
but yeah it's like i said we're still
paying for it so we might as well like
go to something just remind me whenever
you're ready to go we'll go i mean you
got to pay for gas but whenever you're
ready to go we'll go see let's see how
she's doing people she's putting i'm not
doing me i'm not doing anything okay
it's like you're blaming me i'm not
blatant okay
when you're ready to go just tell me
i'll drive us down there
nope okay
north main is good says holy parachute
yeah everybody's saying i've heard that
it was really good i've been wanting to
see it yeah we'll go see it
what day is tomorrow thursday maybe we
should see it tomorrow
yeah i mean i don't have anything else i
mean saturday night saturdays are
usually better right because i don't
have any other work
but
thursdays might work out too if you
don't have a bunch
of thursday we'll go through well i
might i mean like because sometimes [ __ ]
piles on you know what i'm saying
wouldn't mind going down there and
getting some chinese food too
yeah
okay
it's just i never really know because i
don't know like what
what shit's gonna pile on me like
from day to day you know what i'm saying
yep
um yeah so like i said that this car had
been pulled over a couple of times um
but you know for whatever reason they
didn't uh catch them
so once they figured out who these
[ __ ] were and what
[ __ ] car they were driving uh
then they put out a media alert telling
everybody to be on the lookout for this
blue
chevy caprice
so uh basically what ended up happening
with that
was that at 3 15 in the morning on
october 24th
uh
the two guys
were sleeping in the car at a rest stop
near myersville maryland
and a good samaritan who was also at the
rest stop recognized the car
um and called the cops
so the cops came the [ __ ] swat team
came they blocked off all the exits [ __ ]
like that
and uh then they kind of swooped in
and [ __ ] got him
so searching the car uh they found a
stolen bushmaster 223 caliber weapon and
a bipod found in a bag in the car
and uh this
you know the ballistics test that they
did um they determined that this was the
gun that was used in at least 11 of the
14
shootings uh including the one in which
uh nobody got like the one in the window
of michael's that nobody got hurt
so uh yeah as i mentioned earlier uh
attacks all carried out with a
bushmaster xm15 semi-automatic 223
caliber rifle which had been stolen
uh from kind of like a i think it's
called bullseye
something like that like a store
and it also had a holographic weapon
sight on it effective at ranges of 300
meters
and what they had done with the car was
that they pretty much they had a thing
in the back where
um i guess that john muhammad would
drive
and then malvo the kid would like lay in
the back like on his stomach and would
shoot out through they had like a like
kind of a opening
by the
uh the license plate so he could shoot
out the back and then they could get the
[ __ ] out of there so you couldn't so you
couldn't really see
you know nobody was like coming up out
the window and shooting or nothing like
that they were shooting out of like a
little hole in the trunk
so that's how they were able to evade
detection that's why nobody saw them
because
of that i mean they weren't like just
out in the open or anything like that
so once they caught these two
[ __ ] uh they went back
and um at first like they were they were
talking to malvo and
they said at first he seemed like real
like he was kind of quiet at first but
then like they kind of gave him some
food and all this other stuff and then
he started talking and they said at
first he was actually like confessing to
all the [ __ ] almost like he was like
proud of it
like the the really creepy thing was
like the the one that he did the uh the
victims that were shot like um the
victim that was shot outside the home
depot
he said um yeah i targeted like there
was this couple they were putting [ __ ]
in the back of their car
in the parking lot and he was gonna
shoot the husband
but then the husband like moved and he
went around like to the front of the car
to put some in the passenger seat and
then like the wife was there and so he's
like oh well just like he's like oh it
only took me two seconds to like
recalibrate blah blah blah so he was
like really really proud of it which
seemed like really [ __ ] up and he just
like blew the side of her [ __ ] head
off and he was like yeah it was a good
shot and they were like okay
so yeah there was that but he started
talking and so they basically confessed
not only to all that [ __ ] but also to a
bunch of other
ones
that
uh that the cops hadn't really linked to
them prior so actually even though this
particular spree lasted you know three
weeks in october
they actually started killing people way
back in february of 2002.
now
this right here the first ones the first
people that they killed this is kind of
what makes me think that maybe this
whole [ __ ] started because of john
muhammad wanting to get back at his wife
somehow because most of the early [ __ ]
they did
wasn't like related to her directly but
sort of like indirectly you know what
i'm saying but
indirectly enough that it wouldn't
necessarily all be linked together if
you know what i'm saying
february 16th 2002.
there was a girl named kenya nicole cook
she was 21
and
she um was at her aunt's house
and i guess somebody came to the door
and she opened the door and then lee
malvo uh shot her
now
she was actually not expected to be
there i don't think it was supposed to
be just the aunt now her aunt whose name
was isa nichols
was actually friends
with john muhammad's ex-wife whose name
was mildred
um
and
they think that
uh that isa was the person that was
telling mildred to divorce him or like
encouraged her to get divorced from him
so i'm kind of thinking that maybe she
was the first target
but
it wasn't the aunt that got it was the
niece because she was there you know so
i kind of feel like that was how that
was supposed to go down
because she just opened the door and
they shot her
now in february or march uh
malvo said that they were actually out
in california like in la which is not
crazy i mean they did kind of like go
all over the place
um and i think they did some in
washington state too so they were like
driving so this was like several months
before they did the dc sniper shootings
february or march he said
that they had shot and killed a guy in a
robbery like a store like convenience
store or a liquor store or something
like that now malvo did confess to this
it's like yeah we killed the guy
but the fbi couldn't figure out which
particular crime he was talking about so
it's he he didn't make anything else up
everything else had a link to it but
they just hadn't haven't linked any
particular crime to that
but so they think he may be that they
maybe killed somebody in uh l.a it'll
hold up
march 19 2002 a 60 year old man named
jerry taylor
uh was actually on a golf course in
tucson arizona and was killed by a shot
to the chest fired from a long range
uh interestingly john muhammad's sister
lived near this golf course and john
muhammad was visiting her at the time
this shooting took place so again it
seemed like
it seemed like the first [ __ ] was
personal and then he decided he enjoyed
it so it's like let's just go somewhere
else and do like some random [ __ ] i
don't know it just kind of like seemed
like it was
kind of he did that first one and it
[ __ ] then he shook it off it got
easier after that he's like uh
let's go all the way and he was probably
he would have been linked to the first
victim
so he knew eventually he'd become a
suspect so he's gonna go out with a bank
yeah
you know what i mean yeah they might
eventually catch me so i'm gonna go
ahead and go through this [ __ ] plan
they don't catch him on that one then
i'll get away with all this [ __ ]
yeah but they're probably gonna catch me
that's what he's [ __ ] thinking
i mean it did take him a while to catch
him but like i said he they were driving
all over the place i mean this [ __ ]
they didn't link any of this because
none of this was in the same area they
were going like one was in california
one was in like arizona what was that
like nobody would link those together
but he was linked to the first one
yeah
it was a friend of a relative
of his wife or uh yeah the aunt was the
the aunt was a friend of his wife right
denise was the one that was killed but
yeah right
so
that set him off he says [ __ ] it yeah
yeah that's what i'm thinking
and they think they thought he had a 50
chance of getting caught on that
probably but maybe he well and that
happens with serial killers too it's
like they they take that first step like
killing the first victim and then they
get away with it and that like emboldens
them yeah so i kind of feel like that
definitely happened in this situation as
well
um
okay yeah so the next one happened in
may 27th denton texas now i don't know
if they're entirely sure that this has
been linked to them but uh but valvo did
confess to this one
um so you know there's i saw a couple
articles about it where they're like
well they're not entirely sure if this
was them but they're pretty sure it is
there was a guy in it this is a 37 year
old guy named billie jean dylan
and he was on his just out on his
property like he had some kind of rural
land out there and he was down on his
property like [ __ ] around
and uh was shot in the head from a long
distance
this case is technically unsolved
but because um malvo
confessed to it they're sure that it's
probably like a link there
uh because they did find some bullet
fragments there but they didn't uh the
it was inconclusive so they weren't
actually sure if that was related or not
august 1st 2002 a guy named uh john
gayeta who was 51. he was actually uh
malvo slashed his tire
and then when uh when john gaieta came
out
uh of the store he was in a parking lot
this was in louisiana actually in
hammond um he came out and was changing
the tire
and then lee malvo came and shot him in
the neck
now the bullet went through his neck and
came out his back
and then uh
so he played dead and then lee malvo
stole his wallet
now after uh malvo had left uh john
gaita who was still alive uh ran to a
gas station
and uh then went to the hospital and he
actually was fine i mean not fine but he
recovered like completely they let him
out of the hospital like an hour later
so
so he ended up being good but he played
dead so he lived
um september 5th 2002 10 30 p.m
55 year old man named paul laruffa who
owned a pizzeria
uh was locking up his restaurant in
clinton maryland and was shot six times
at close range he also survived what was
it you shot with uh i don't know this
might not have been because like i said
the rifle
yeah that's what i'm saying that was
just one that they used but i'm not
really sure yeah must be some pistol
yeah at close range that six shots that
dude wouldn't be like walking around but
um
yeah they did actually find they knew
that um that this victim was one of
theirs because later on when they caught
uh malvo and muhammad they found this
dude's laptop in that car in their car
so they knew that uh that he had robbed
so they were like robbing people at
first too yeah like they weren't doing
that later later they were just leaving
for the campaign yeah they were just
sniping people later but like at first
they were robbing people like robbing
liquor stores [ __ ] like that right well
they needed money for this campaign yeah
to go on their [ __ ] right road trip
yeah we needed gas food ammos that kind
of [ __ ] yeah that's what they're doing
september 14 2002. uh a guy named
repenter benny obroy who was 22
he actually worked at a liquor store
and he was uh locking up the liquor
store he was outside the liquor store
and he got shot in the back uh he also
survived
september 15 2002 uh muhammad rasheed
also shot uh outside of another liquor
store in brandywine maryland uh also
survived and he testified at the trial
as well
so you know so a lot of these first ones
it had to be like a different firearm
uh
they're using this one i kind of feel
like probably
some people like well why would you use
a pistol if you have a rifle pistols a
lot easier to use from a vehicle they
probably pull up on them in a car
it's nowhere near as loud okay
even a good sized pistol like nine
millimeter which is the standard it's a
pop gun
especially compared to a five five six
like an m16 that's a bow ultrasonic
[ __ ] [ __ ] big crack and [ __ ]
echoes throughout
if you don't want to call much attention
you use a pistol
from a distance most most witnesses who
don't know what pistols sound like think
it's a firecracker because that's kind
of what it sounds like from a distance
but a rifle now
you go that's a gun yeah sounds like a
damn
lightning [ __ ] strike
echoes throughout the [ __ ] area
so that's why they're doing that
yeah and i kind of feel like and maybe
this next victim this is probably like
answering our question right here yeah
uh september 21st 2002
uh 12 15 in the morning a man named uh
million walder
waldemariam uh who was 41 he was
actually fatally shot in the head and
back with a 22 caliber pistol oh this
was in atlanta georgia
now he was actually helping out there
was like a package store and uh him and
his the guy that owned it we're closing
up and uh somebody just came up and shot
him he died okay
explain this
if you when you look at the movies you
see these
silenced pistols they'll have like a
nine millimeter or a five brothers
with a silencer on it they're gonna call
it a silencer all right and [ __ ] dude
shoot somebody in this pink pink pink
it's like man you're hiding the fact
that [ __ ] oh man nobody even knows
you shot anything
yeah [ __ ] that's not the way it is
it's not called a silencer it's called a
suppressor
and a suppressed
major caliber like nine millimeter or 45
units doesn't matter
bullet weight or anything if it's as
long as it's subsonic
a suppressed
subsonic pistol
puts out about as much decibels or sound
as an unsuppressed 22 caliber pistol
so a 9 millimeter
suppressed
sounds like an unsuppressed 22.
well like i said earlier before
everything has to do with shot placement
if you're good
and you're at close range
you don't need the suppressor
a 22 caliber unsuppressed pistol puts
out the same amount of decibels or
sounds
as a suppressed nine millimeter so if
you dr if you trust yourself and at the
ranges you're talking about in this
mission you can use an unsuppressed an
unsuppressed 22 caliber pistol
and uh the chances of someone really
hearing that
and identifying it as shots
especially at night
very excellent very low
now there's a caveat
you suppress a major major caliber
pistol like nine millimeter and above
you will hear it okay
uh
it's not like you're hiding the fact
that shots have been fired people will
know shots have been fired
but if you suppress something like 22
30 32 acp and 380 the minor pistol
pistol calibers
sometimes depending on the construction
of the pistol you can hide the fact that
shots have been fired
there are suppressed 32s and 22s and
380s out there
where the loudest sound
out of the whole firing process is the
impact of the bullet that that's making
the most sound
that's pretty [ __ ] impressive
very impressive
now
caveat
most of those pistols are not
semi-automatic most of them are a single
shot
they'll take a semi-auto pistol and
[ __ ] convert it over to single shot
to where it'll fire
and then you have to manually operate
the slide because they're
because
gas operation of opening the slide makes
more noise you'll hear that
so
a lot of those pistols were [ __ ]
modified to where you can push a lever
up and it [ __ ] locks the slide into
place to make it a single shot pistol
you pull back on it that that little
switch falls and then you let go of it
and it'll fire a new it'll chamber a new
round then you push the button up again
and take another shot
so
that's what they're doing there they
just took a 22 and they used that
because it's not as loud it's kind of
like it's
kind of like a suppressed nine
millimeter
as long as the shot placement is good
it'll be just as effective
okay
okay so they do know what they're doing
this dude's an idiot he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but he doesn't know what he's
doing
when it comes to firearms applications
okay so the same day as that shooting in
atlanta georgia
uh 19 hours later
a 52 year old liquor store clerk named
claudine parker
was shot in the chest and killed during
a robbery in montgomery alabama this was
the case that um
john muhammad was talking about when he
called the police uh you know was trying
to like prove that he was the real
shooter
uh so she was killed uh there was
another uh young woman working there
kelly adams she was 24 and she was shot
through the neck but she lived
now as i mentioned this uh fingerprints
they found at this scene would
eventually end up
linking up with uh you know the
fingerprint they found from one of the
letters from the dc snipers but it took
like a month for them to make that uh
connection
september 23rd 2002 6 30 p.m
uh a man named hong m ballinger 45 years
old
shot in the head and killed with a
bushmaster rifle which is what they used
for the dc ones uh this was in baton
rouge louisiana okay bushmaster it's a
good that's the one they used for all
the shootings because earlier on i was
saying i don't know what brand they used
she just told me it's bushmaster i
thought i said that earlier okay
bushmasters actually
okay the one that is used by the us army
especially during this time
was made by colt under contract
colt didn't design it okay eugene stoner
designed it
when he was working with his company
called armalite all right that's who
designed that originally okay so colt
was contracted to make it because
armalite was a little bitty company they
couldn't
they couldn't make all that [ __ ] for the
us army
now colt
was a company that was up north and they
were kind of [ __ ] they were in a blue
state okay and they believed in gun
control they did not want to sell that
rifle
to civilians
even though it was totally legal uh it
fit all the
all the criteria of [ __ ] something
that you could sell legally there are a
lot of other companies that sold things
that were like that okay
but colt didn't want to sell it
to civilians they came out with some
target models but that's an exception
all right now
another company appeared
that made a clone of it an exact clone
bushmaster
and the bushmasters were real good
they gave you kind of what what their
selling point was is that they sold you
a civilian legal semi-auto version of
what the us army had it looked just like
it except for the markings
they were real good real good
so
the bushmaster was not a cheap
rifle it was good um now
later on their quality kind of suffered
during one of the gun band period the
bushmaster brand kind of got tarnished
where it was really good and then it
went bad and then it got better again
and now i think it's called windham
armory wyndham something it's been
renamed now
but uh yeah good rifle okay good
yeah so this last this shooting here
that which was the last one of the first
uh you know ones before they went to dc
and did that kind of [ __ ] was yeah that
was the first one of the of that set
that they used the bushmaster that was
what they used uh for the dc uh things
and that was in baton rouge louisiana
which interestingly
was where
uh john allen muhammad was originally
from yeah it's funny because i didn't
know they killed anybody in louisiana
they did they killed people all over the
place
all over the place
and they might have killed more people
they're not entirely sure i think
they're i think their kill count was 17
that they know of so they were just
driving around shooting all kinds of
[ __ ] yeah they were just driving from
state to state and like i said it was 10
people in the dc sniper attacks but they
had killed at least seven people prior
to that that they didn't find out about
until later on
so yeah so john muhammad so let's talk
about these two [ __ ]
backgrounds
so john muhammad was actually born john
allen williams as i mentioned in baton
rouge louisiana
now uh his family moved to new orleans
uh his mom when his mom got diagnosed
with breast cancer and then she died
when he was three
so his mom died and then his dad left
nice
uh so he kind of so williams kind of got
left with his uh grandfather and an aunt
1987 when he was 27 years old he joined
the nation of islam
now
i've heard differing things because
wikipedia said that he changed his last
name to muhammad in 2001.
but another source i said said no he
changed his name to muhammad when he
joined the nation of islam in 1987. so i
don't know which one is true um but
it doesn't really matter probably
spiritually changed it in 87 when he
joined yeah it doesn't really matter but
yeah he joined the nation of islam in uh
87.
now as i mentioned he had been married a
couple of times and he had a wife named
mildred at this point
and they had three kids i think
and
he'd been in the military for a while
which i'll get into in a little bit but
from at least what i saw like for some
interviews with some friends of his
that said he seemed like an okay dude
uh at first
you know like he seemed he was quiet and
they said he was kind of like strict
with his kids but not like abusive
strict
but they said when he came back from
like being in the military he'd done a
couple tours they said he wasn't really
the same like they said he was a lot
darker although his wife did um
eventually have to get a restraining
order against because of abuse and stuff
so it might be the case that his friends
didn't see
all of what was going on
but so she kind of like files for
divorce she gets a restraining order
because she said that uh you know now
she's afraid of him
and
they basically said well they gave the
kids to her obviously because he was
acting a ass
and so as i mentioned earlier on in the
show he decides that he's going to take
it upon himself to kidnap them
he not only kidnapped the children he
took them out of the country he took
them to antigua
that was in 1999.
um
and then well the weird thing about it
was then like later on he came back like
and he had to go to court for the [ __ ]
and like he really legitimately thought
that they would listen to him about how
he wanted like visitation and stuff
they're like dude
you kidnapped your kids like after the
whole legal process went through
and they said you know so it's like why
would you get visitation out but yeah so
like i said it was just kind of like
i don't know a lot of his own [ __ ] was
like himself only had himself to blame
you know so he took the kids out of the
country in 1999 and when he was in
antigua allegedly uh he started making
money
by doing
uh credit card fraud and also like
making
fake passports and id for people like so
they could immigrate to the us so he'd
do that kind of crap
now
during this time period
he
met
lee malvo
now lee malvo uh was just kind of a kid
at this point uh you know he was a
teenager
now lee malva was jamaican actually
um so it was right around this time and
i'll kind of get into his backstory a
little bit too but they kind of
developed like a father-son type
situation
now
later on like after they caught muhammad
i don't know how much of this is like
[ __ ] or not because like i said i'm
pretty sure that his motive was one he
was a nut case and two
he was trying to like get back at the
world for his ex-wife [ __ ] him over
and taking his kids away or something
and he was just going about it the most
roundabout way possible
but they said like after they caught him
um he said yeah like osama bin laden
he's [ __ ] awesome and um yeah those
september 11 attacks yeah that was cool
like he said that he thought that he was
way too good
yeah that's what like yeah so he did say
[ __ ] like that but they determined later
on that he didn't really have anything
to do with no he's gonna do it
yeah well he saw that happen so he
thought it was time to rise up
but that's also [ __ ] he's making
that ex he's making that excuse what it
really was is he wanted his kids back he
couldn't stand his wife he wanted to
kill a bunch of people he was pissed off
yeah
he thought he killed him he was going to
kill a bunch of random people because
[ __ ] him
all right
the white devil all right and all this
kind of [ __ ] there was a lot of black
nationalism involved in this too a race
was a factor
and then he says and one of the ones i'm
going to kill is mac's wife and that
would then i'll get the kids
yeah because that's how that would
totally work yeah because when she's
dead i'll get the kids it probably
wouldn't have probably gone to grandma
well yeah it's probably what had really
happened well because she had filed like
a restraining order against him like
and apparently she had like pretty
pretty good evidence that he was like
abusive right because they wouldn't let
him have the kids so there must have
been a reason probably would have gone
to the grandma
i'm imagining her uncles or aunts or
something yeah it wouldn't have gone to
him so he he's tripping that's not how
that works out it's like i have an idea
i'll just kill their mom and then
they'll have to give me the kids i'm
like no they that's not how that works
because i killed all those other people
that never suspect me because it's just
all random that was his i kind of think
that was his plan well yeah he said like
well it wouldn't be me he they're just
caught up she just yeah she just got
killed by a serial killer [ __ ] happened
it totally wasn't me yeah you think i'd
kill 20 other people for this to get my
kids no never nobody would be that crazy
yeah that's what he was doing that's how
i interpreted what he said yeah
yeah i think i i agree with you yeah i
think that's kind of what he's
camouflaging himself against all those
other murders but here's the deal no
sane [ __ ] will do that no person
who doesn't want to kill somebody won't
will do that he wanted to kill others
yeah you gotta wanna do that yeah he and
and he and he didn't and he didn't want
to get his own hands dirty he's got his
lackey doing it
yeah okay yeah he's like i'm gonna
document him
yeah he's a coward yeah
she should have done the [ __ ] himself if
he really believed in it
but
no he dragged he drove this kid into it
yeah
who's doing six life sentences
which i feel bad for the kid he was 17
he should have known but not but [ __ ] i
was dumb at 17 too he probably [ __ ]
gave the dude a good line and filled his
head full of [ __ ] hey we're going to
war with the [ __ ] with with america
these white devils and this and that and
the slavers we're going to [ __ ] wipe
them out
and [ __ ] osama's on our side you see
we're winning we knocking that we
knocked down their biggest buildings you
probably filled his head with all kinds
of [ __ ]
at 17 you might be
you're gonna be more open to hearing
that kind of [ __ ] well like i said the
kid didn't really have a father figure
either and he was kind of like
vulnerable also like i said look at that
not excusing it but yeah he's looking
and he goes he's right man we've got
we've gotten away with it [ __ ] all
these times he's got to be right
all the news is talking about us we're
winning
that's
i see it i can imagine it yeah i can too
and i can imagine being 17 thinking that
you're that it's all good that yeah
we're yeah we're going to win
yeah
we're fighting the
enemy yeah i i do it's a lot more
complicated than that kid
i feel like every solo in the middle of
everything is i mean
it's a lot more complicated please don't
yeah i kind of feel like everybody's
like oh simple solutions i'm like
nothing has a simple solution everything
is black and white everything really
everything is way more complicated and
way more nuanced
there's always
always like way way more details right
always everything is way more
complicated
uh but yeah later on uh lee malvo
actually testified
that
uh john muhammad had told him that we're
gonna do that extortion attempt because
remember they left that thing we want 10
million dollars from the government or
whatever yeah and it's like we're going
to use that money
and we're going to set up a camp in
canada
and we're going to
round up homeless kids and train them as
terrorists that was what he was going to
do was like do a terrorist camp that's
what he said anyway i don't know if he
ever sitting in there making moves on
both of us jenny oh yeah
[Laughter]
go ahead and read what he said
yeah american military 100 i'm just here
for the pretty blue hair chick thank you
it's purple actually but close enough uh
just kidding i'm only here for pseudo
leather daddy honking back sitting aside
yeah yeah
i heard you bro
yeah we saw that
yeah so as i said his wife uh milton she
was his second wife second ex-wife and
she had gotten a restraining order
against him because of abuse now john
muhammad had been arrested before
um because
when the restraining order was in play
uh he had like they found him and he had
a weapon so it was a weapons violation
because when you have that when you have
a restraining order you're not uh
you know you can't have a weapon
so
so he had got arrested for that now okay
so let's talk about his like military
career for a little bit so he actually
enlisted in uh the louisiana army
national guard in uh baton rouge in
august of 1978. he was a combat engineer
and then he transferred on to the
regular army in 85.
so he was a mechanic truck driver uh
metal worker
um and as i said he had the expert
rifleman's badge he's rear echelon
though yeah yeah and he did several
tours he did one tour with the 15th
engineer battalion fort lewis 1985. yeah
1981 uh 1991 he served in the gulf war
uh his company dismantled iraqi chemical
warfare rockets yeah uh he got a bunch
of um service medals for that
um and then in 92 he went to fort ord
california with 13th engineers 1993 back
at fort lewis with the 14th engineer
battalion it's all starting to come in i
didn't know what what units he was in
but now that i see you know those aren't
bad units [ __ ] the army in that era
didn't have bad units but these are rear
echelon units these are support units
that's why he's got this kid doing it
all right he wouldn't come from a
[ __ ]
a unit of killers
this dude was from [ __ ] one of my
units he would be behind the trigger
dude you're [ __ ] bad for that i'd be
didn't beat that dude's ass he's got the
kid doing it well he's dead down so yeah
he's dead now i beat that motherfucker's
head he's got the kids doing it because
he's not mad enough to do it himself
yeah he's just driving the car yeah i'm
just gonna drive the car you do all the
shooting
because you're small enough to lay in
the back of the car yeah full [ __ ]
yeah i know that's not probably that's
probably what he told him that's what he
told the kid [ __ ]
he just [ __ ] um
yeah
yeah my [ __ ] mind's [ __ ] i'm
seeing lightning bolts now
sparks and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
could be an x army makes me want to
[ __ ] like punish him you know what i
mean
i i i know he's thinking that
[ __ ] needs his ass beat i'd
stomp a [ __ ]
now he's got that kid in trouble
you know what i mean
yeah which as we were talking about
before had that kid not met this
[ __ ]
it's likely that he would have turned
out okay
but right
such a you know if he was a real man
he'd have been back there behind that
[ __ ] trigger shooting himself instead
he's got the kid doing it
yeah not implying that
that a real man goes around like killing
random civilians that's not what i'm
implying i'm just saying you know what
i'm talking about if you really had
balls if you really believed in what you
were doing if you really [ __ ] thought
that you were on the right side of this
[ __ ] you'd be behind that trigger
no he's got the kid doing it
yeah there you go he's a [ __ ] coward
that's what i mean all right [ __ ] up
he can't even [ __ ] face what it is
that he wants to do
you need to get stomped for some [ __ ]
like that
i got bee's nest in the comment he's x
army
nests would stomp that [ __ ] too
no you don't [ __ ] go out you never
here's the this is just something that
we [ __ ] know it's not just the us
army it's all professional armies you
never ever ever ever ever
ever
ask a subordinate to do something that
you will not do yourself
and i didn't see him behind any trigger
you have time not that we know of it
seemed like the kid mostly said that he
i bet he was the kid mostly
so
maybe he shot one of those dudes in the
back
with the pistol
like some of the early questions some of
their maybe
to show the kid
but still
why are you even involved in the kid
what do you need him for well i mean why
are you even doing this [ __ ] yeah first
place not going no no no no no
let's go ahead and say this is something
you want to do all right what's the kid
there for
why do you need him
you know
it's a crutch if you ask me
yeah yeah
i'm just saying this is just making me
want to [ __ ] piss on a [ __ ]
well at least you can find his grave
probably yeah outside the prison where
they executed him [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah so he got uh honorably discharged
yeah uh
in 1994 with the rank of sergeant so
he'd been for 16
years
uh had several awards and blah blah blah
now uh
as i
mentioned that
probably like the defense attorneys at
least at the trial
were like they suspected that even
though obviously he killed like a bunch
of random people that his whole thing
even though he made like a big show and
i'll kind of get into this little in a
minute
but of he had like this big [ __ ] plan
of like kind of a terrorist type of plot
but they're kind of suspecting that
it wasn't that he was just mad at his
wife for taking his kids away and was
gonna like punish the world because of
it so they they're pretty sure that that
was the
ultimate goal whatever he wanted to
dress it up as yeah
so lee malvo
uh the younger of the two
born in 1985
and he was actually from kingston
jamaica
now uh
so what ended up happening was that
i guess like the
the his mom and dad were not married and
then the mom actually left the dad in
1990 so when lee was five
and then when lee was nine they
he went off to live with his aunt marie
and stayed there for a year and they
said that he was actually like pretty uh
bright he was like a really good student
he was you know [ __ ] like that so he got
into like good schools and whatnot
now he actually got baptized into the
seventh-day adventist church when he was
14. that was 1999
and then moved to antigua which is where
he met
muhammad
his mom was living there at that time
and like i said he was very good in
school nobody thought anything about it
he seemed like a good kid
now uh so right around 1999 lee and his
mom
met john muhammad in antigua
and
because
uh
lee perhaps had grown up without a
father because like i said his dad left
when he was you know five years old or
his mom left his dad when when he was f
uh five so he didn't really have a
father figure
um
so he started i'd kind of some sources
said that um that john muhammad dated
his mom for a time i don't know if
that's the case but he was just like
always around you know what i mean and
they developed a very strong friendship
like a father-son type of thing
and i think too they kind of approached
him because as i mentioned earlier john
muhammad sort of made his living
making like procuring fake documents for
people who wanted to like fake passports
and stuff like that
so
i think that uh
that lee's mom wanted to emigrate to the
u.s and didn't have uh the [ __ ] to do it
so i think maybe that that's how they
kind of came in contact with him as well
because they wanted some fake documents
or wanted some help getting into the
united states so there was that because
like i said muhammad was an american he
was born in louisiana so so there was
that
so later uh they went to
so his mom like went to fort myers in
florida using the fake documents that
muhammad had made now she left her son
back in antigua with him
um and said you know i'll come back for
you or i'll send for you like later on
when i get like all the [ __ ] set up yeah
when i get all the [ __ ] set up
um
now at this point like i said uh you
know he's kind of still a teenager
and
so in 2000 early 2001 uh john muhammad
you know converts him to islam because
like i said he was seventh-day adventist
prior to that
and started
you know and this is very grooming very
cult-like behavior
starts um
like isolating him from his mom you know
like uh yeah she doesn't want you or she
left or blah blah blah like that type of
thing
so he's like you know i'm i'll look
after you i'm like your dad blah blah
blah
so at this point like lee comes into
miami in 2001 illegally
and then
uh in december of 2001
both him and his mom
were caught by the border patrol in
bellingham washington
uh now he got released in january uh on
fifteen hundred dollars bond but then he
went him and muhammad went to lake and
they lived in a homeless shelter like in
that town now he actually
enrolled in high school
listing john muhammad as his dad
and then at that point like i said he
was still going to school but he wasn't
really doing as well as he had you know
when he was still
at home
now when they were in this particular
area this was when they think that lee
stole
the rifle that they would ultimately use
for the thing he stole it from a place
called bullseye
shooter supply
and there was a
shooting range like next to the gun shop
and he would go over there and
target shoot
him and
him and his dad now
because he was technically an illegal
immigrant and because john muhammad
was um had a restraining order neither
of them were legally uh really allowed
to own firearms but you know
obviously that didn't stop him did it
because he just stole it
from that store and that's what they
ended up using
so as we mentioned before um
when we're talking about motive
we kind of feel like i mean everybody
kind of feels like um
that probably the the impetus for it was
john muhammad
his wife taking his kids away and him
not being able to get them back
and so he came up with this crackpot
plan
hey if she's just a random victim of a
serial killer then nobody can blame me
for the [ __ ] and i'll end up getting my
kids
now
the weird thing about it though is that
when like after they caught them
and they put lee malvo in jail
he started writing
all this stuff about uh you know doing
jihad against the united states and all
this other kind of stuff so muhammad had
been like filling his head with all this
kind of crap
but they said he also they didn't take
it super seriously because it's like he
drew pictures of like and i saw there's
if you see some documentaries they show
like some of his journals and stuff
and uh he had drawn like these pictures
of like osama bin laden and
uh saddam hussein and stuff like that
but then he was also like super into the
matrix
and he had like characters from the
matrix in there and one documentary i
saw was like pointing out
that
one of the things that john muhammad
would do allegedly was that he got him
real into like that matrix kind of stuff
just in a way that oh we're fighting
back against the system
uh you know and uh
and maybe two like in a way oh
everything's a simulation so almost kind
of like deep trying to dehumanize people
and he got him like really into like you
know first-person shooter video games
and stuff like that what's a fantasy
world yeah he was trying so he was
trying to like
get him to a point where it's like
you're
you're an enlightened person like
they're all just you know
yeah they're all npcs he was trying to
like get him in that kind of mindset
which like i said they do that a lot
with uh you know they try to like
dehumanize try to dehumanize the enemy
because it makes it easier yeah that's
not just that's military yeah there's
like that's what i was going to say they
always institutions
anywhere that has to kill people um
that's what they can do yeah that's what
they'll do killing and fighting or
resisting you always
the enemy is the enemy they're not like
you
yeah you can't live side by side with
them yeah it's either you or them
not to say that that's wrong
there are some situations where that's
absolutely
right absolutely
you know
soviet russia and [ __ ] nazi germany
could not survive side by side even
though they had a [ __ ] pact for a
while when they went at each other that
was it it was either one or the other
yeah so it's not just it's not just you
know
it's not [ __ ]
just
all of history's like that
lion x warrior says geez seventh day
adventist switching good nation of islam
what a major head [ __ ] yeah right that's
what i was thinking yeah yeah because uh
yeah malvo was raised seventh day at
venice
uh and went to school when he you know
when he was in jacob
now look
i'm gonna say something kind of in
defense a nation to islam
which is in a weird way nation of islam
isn't about this and it's not normal
islam all right
middle eastern islam rejects nation of
islam it's an american thing
it's a
very much occult okay it's a black
nationalist black empowerment cult
it's not all bad it's a mixture of good
and bad
uh there's
i kind of like farrakhan uh well in fair
khan came out and said i don't know yeah
i'm not nothing to do with this
[ __ ] no thanks farrakhan's quite
a character all right um but i don't
take fair khan seriously
uh fair khan is kind of like the black
version of elrond hubbard all right
which airline hubbard i like elrond
hubbard would i become a scientologist
no no was l ron hubbard like a good dude
no
it's just these are the [ __ ]
entertaining things that happen in life
you know what i mean they've got life is
filled with [ __ ] characters
i [ __ ] love scientology for
the lulls in a lot of ways and i mean
they're [ __ ] they
they come up with some wild [ __ ] man
do i want to hang out with
scientologists [ __ ] no they're [ __ ]
every one of my run across is a [ __ ]
well they kind of [ __ ] up people's lives
yeah yeah no yeah
but uh you can sit back and listen
especially kids that are raised yeah
that's correct yeah but you can sit back
and listen to videos about [ __ ]
scientology about what's going on in
there and it's a [ __ ] trip
all right the world would not be very
interesting if you didn't have people
like this yeah i mean [ __ ] they're
just interesting [ __ ] thanks you know
um
was that ron hubbard a bad guy
not really
they liked him
he was an occult figure
uh was
he did some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] man but
but he wasn't a bad guy he wasn't a
murderer or anything you know he's just
not that we know he was just wrong about
[ __ ] he was bullshitting yeah
bullshitting a lot [ __ ] his own kind
of it's his own kind of thing but it's
he's bullshitted a lot because if you
[ __ ] a lot i mean even if you didn't
do anything yourself i mean that you're
wrong that could lead to
yeah people other people take that or
killed yeah yeah so it's like he's not
blameless
well i don't think he realized that that
would happen
that's true i don't think he realized it
he was just uh he was he was just trying
to make a buck he was grifting
grifting and drifting in his lifetime
and spinning a narrative
uh that would [ __ ]
afford him the life that but he died in
a weird way he basically died [ __ ] in
hiding [ __ ] talking to alien souls
and [ __ ] crazy doing drugs
you know with briefcases of money around
everywhere david miscavige bringing in
more briefcases of money
it's a wild [ __ ] story have another
briefcase which is part of my
fascination with tom cruise is that tom
cruise somehow got [ __ ]
tied up in that wild ass [ __ ] story
it's [ __ ] weird man but but the world
is weird all right it is so uh i just
wanted to say the [ __ ] these guys
here they really
really didn't have anything to do with
nation of islam
and nothing to do with islamic terror
they were their own terror they were
trying to i mean i think he back like i
said yeah i think that was like
something they came up with maybe after
the fact or
like mohammed said that sounds like a
good idea right but like i said i think
he was justifying after the fact because
like i said you have to think this
happened only like a year after 9 11.
and so he's like oh everybody's like
afraid of terrorists and stuff i'll show
you terrorism and it's like but
also i'll [ __ ] up my ex-wife and [ __ ] up
her day like you know what i mean so i
kind of feel like it was like a yeah
justified after the fact after the fact
yeah he was trying to like scare me it i
mean it is terrorism in a sense because
you're terrorizing an entire community
yeah but it wasn't islamic terror but it
wasn't for any political end or
religious and or religious end no
nothing to do with mecca and those as
islamic
during the people against a time of like
heightened uh awareness about that
so yeah
he had his own personal reasons i don't
think it had anything to do right with
that but yeah um oh
let's see all right
yeah so uh
so during the trial
uh john muhammad's trap
lee malvo testified
that john muhammed had a three-phase
plan like i said i'm talking about this
terrorist play
so this is three-phase plan phase one um
you're gonna like plan map and you
practice around dc so after the
shootings
uh you know they'll be able to like uh
you know very quickly like move on to
the next location without getting caught
now his goal in phase one according to
lee malvo hold on they attacking me for
saying that it's a cult no nation islam
is a cult but just because i say it's a
cult doesn't mean cults aren't naturally
bad or wrong or anything occult just
just nobody's attacking you he said well
he's attacking all right no he nobody's
attacking you oh okay it says well said
tom okay well okay
i'm just saying that it is a cult
a cult is a small religion they believe
what they believe
uh
i think it's a lot of the [ __ ] that they
say is right it's about empowerment and
self-improvement
uh but that was the same thing with
[ __ ] anton levay in the original
church to say similar
um
it's just black empowerment black
improvement
um
i do think that there's an element of
scam and [ __ ] of course you know people
got to make money
but
that's just the way churches are you
know i mean it's a church is it islam
no
no it's an american creation it's not
islam
not really yeah it's not really all that
similar i don't i don't really know that
much about it but from what i've read
about it it's not really my my best
the best way i could ever spin nation of
islam
is that it's it's black scientology and
scientology and nation islam have an
alliance they actually work together
they do yeah it's real similar it's
black scientology
not to say that that's a bad thing
some people might need that
does the average [ __ ] need that
no you can learn that [ __ ] on your own
okay there's an element of [ __ ]
there's an element of larping in all
these religions well some people like to
belong to something yeah they just won't
belong i don't right i don't want to
belong to anything leave me alone
[ __ ] them you can figure that [ __ ] out
on your own that's what that's what i'm
saying yeah
it's like and like i said it's like look
if i can't figure it out on my own then
who the [ __ ] like some other
[ __ ] not me they're not gonna
tell me anything about me you don't need
magic clothes and special haircuts and
[ __ ] buildings and all this [ __ ] to
make yourself feel good you don't need
that
just
live your life as a person read some
[ __ ] books all right
have fun
have a drink for christmas build
yourself up into something you don't
need them
and yeah the reason why that [ __ ]
flourished back in the day is because it
was a pre-internet era people were low
and feel they didn't have anything
better to do
the flow of information was very
restricted
uh you have the internet now you don't
need that kind of stuff
yeah i mean honestly just like i said
honestly i would never go back to like
because now [ __ ] man i can just i was
like wow i can just like sit around
watching horror movies and writing scary
stories and like making videos about it
all information thousands of people see
them and it's like that's pretty cool
you can get all the information you can
buy
anything anywhere you can meet anyone
anywhere you can make friends online
anywhere [ __ ] uh find the local clubs
where people are like you where you can
go [ __ ] hang out [ __ ] a party with
them it's just it's
so the the scene has changed
these old religions and [ __ ] [ __ ]
cults that's one of the reasons why
they're dying is just that they're
obsolete
internet is serving the [ __ ]
function that those used to have if you
understand i'm talking about that you
don't need them anymore
well i mean the internet like i said it
establishes its own communities right
and i kind of feel like a lot that's why
a lot of people used to go to church
even if they weren't really all that
devout or anything like that it was like
a community type of thing everybody go
and you everybody knew each other and
everybody with similar interests and
[ __ ] like that but you don't need that
anymore no you just don't eat anymore
you don't need that anymore tammy says
we belong to the cult of pookie yeah
called a pookie
call to pookie the entire universe
understands pookie they see it and they
go yeah yeah that's right
all faiths religions creeds and racists
can see pookie and understand
the inner knowledge okay the inner
gnosis of pookieism they see and they go
yes that is a pookie where is poopy i
don't know she's usually like hanging
out in here yeah
we matter which we should probably hats
break through all boundaries cute cats
everybody understands everybody
everybody understands that yeah pookie's
mad at me because i only brushed her
once today is that what it is yes you
were being stingy with the brush yeah
she's like rush action you suck mama
brush action every time i flee every
time i walk past that dress that
dressing table she jumps up on the sink
and like looks at me and goes bye yeah
yeah yeah
brush brush
and i'm just like i can't right now i
don't have time and she's like
she asked me to open the closet door at
least three times a day she goes up the
closed door
and i open it she just looks in and goes
okay
okay
[Laughter]
[ __ ] cats man or funny she's a
nutcase yeah we love her though she's
like so she's so spoiled
she says well
but yeah uh so yeah so what did i say
okay phase one phase one uh the goal of
phase one
was to kill six white people a day for
30 days so
how many people is that 180 people yeah
like all together yeah
um and then lee said well that was phase
one but it didn't work out the way we
wanted
because of traffic
okay and um
and we didn't get a clear shot or
getaway routes blah blah blah because
like i said they didn't shoot they just
shot random people like most of them
some of them were white but some of them
were
were not white i mean some were like
indian i think there were some that were
like hispanic i think they were they
were just like all over the place well
like i said that's why the cops were
having such a hard time because they're
like well this wasn't it wasn't race it
wasn't gender which you know the people
didn't have shot black people though um
that was a good idea oh i don't know did
they no just
they were shooting the general public
but they'd probably pass on black people
maybe
yeah because i kind of feel like a
factor in a lot of these yeah i'm trying
to think of like but yeah they were like
we couldn't really determine and they
said look it's men women it's old people
it's young people it didn't really look
but it just looked like a random
psychologist a little bit psychologists
will tell you that it's harder to kill a
person of the same race of you if
they're another race it's easier because
you're they're not you don't identify
with them as much i don't know if that's
the same i don't know if that's changed
but that would that's what they used to
say
you know like at least back up into the
80s and their 90s
which that's kind of what helped in
warfare if you're going to [ __ ]
war with another country that is also
another race it's a lot easier it's
harder if you're going to war with a
country that is the same race as you
like
england you know
america versus germany is a little
little harder on
on people he's just shooting a person
looks just like you
yeah
i mean there's a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of anecdotal [ __ ] stories about
germans and americans [ __ ] drawn down
and drawing down on each other and they
couldn't pull the trigger because they
looked too much alike
you know even during d-day
rangers coming up the [ __ ] mountain
coming up that [ __ ] sheer cliff wall
to knock out those guns they had germans
up there throwing grenades on them and
some guys american guys said it was
climbing up and a german guy pointed a
[ __ ]
sub machine gun right at me but he
couldn't pull the trigger
yeah well the thing about it too it
might not i mean yeah i'm sure race is
probably a factor but
i think it's harder to like shoot
somebody in the face when they're like
right there when you're like looking
them right in the eyes it's much easier
to like pick people off like far away
because it's yeah it's like not a person
you're not seeing them well like i think
we talked about this a little bit on the
road rage show too that it's much easier
to demonize somebody that's like in a
car because you're not seeing them as a
person you're just seeing an object yeah
you're mad at the car then you see the
person you know that's mad at him yeah
so if i mean i kind of feel like
hopefully mostly few people would be
able to actually just go up to a random
ass innocent person and just shoot them
right in the face yeah no matter what
race they were
um just because you can see that that's
a person you know what i mean you can
look in their [ __ ] eyes and see like
that they're scared and [ __ ] like that
so i mean some people could because some
people back in the 40s back in the 40s
when they were doing all those
statistics during the world war ii data
some of the greatest [ __ ] statistical
data was taken by the us army
of the [ __ ] u.s armed forces during
world war ii they were taking iq data
they were taking they were in processing
everybody i [ __ ] read i [ __ ] read
a whole thing on it
that social engineering a lot of what we
believe or at least back in those days
came from world war ii and this in the
data that they'd compiled about iq race
everything
[ __ ]
back in the 40s it probably been easier
to kill a person of another race you
didn't have mass media
okay yeah he didn't see foreigners that
much you saw somebody from another
country like a japanese person and you
man what is that you shot him
you know and they were the same thing
against us they were taking [ __ ]
usgis and cutting [ __ ] if they
captured them they'd do things like
[ __ ] string them up cut their
[ __ ] genitals off and [ __ ] make them
eat it and [ __ ] leave them out there
and cut their heads off because it was
easier for them to do
the japanese were doing [ __ ] just as bad
to the chinese and that's from our point
of view they looked to be the same race
to us but not for the japanese they saw
the chinese as some totally different
okay
it was stronger back then because you
didn't have
telecommunications and mass
telecommunications well you're not
exposed to people of like all races like
all the time like you are nowadays
exactly
so
seeing a person from another [ __ ]
race back in the 40s is like seeing an
alien
you know a person from another planet
he just didn't
react to him the same way
it's not the same way now you know what
i mean we're just we see each other all
the time because everything's normalized
which is good yeah i think that's a good
thing [ __ ] we're all human beings we
can all cross breed okay yeah it's not a
big difference there are there are
differences but there's no they're not
big differences you know it's it's all
yeah not really enough to write home
about no it's mostly just having to do
with [ __ ] what climate our ancestors
[ __ ] grew up and what what was being
selected for in that area or sometimes
like some races are more likely to get a
certain disease than others you're right
but it's like i said it's not really
that huge yeah it's not that big
of a difference it all boils down really
the future of mankind is all about who
will you have children with
that's really all that matters now
who will you have children with who will
you marry and have children with
okay so yeah so phase one right uh where
they were supposed to kill 180 white
people they said yeah heavy traffic um
put the cab wash on that so they just
which like i know that's [ __ ] up but
it's like that kind of made me laugh
like when i read that i was like really
you had this big terroristic plan we're
gonna kill 180 white people and well the
traffic was bad though i mean come on
it's just like it just sounds like such
a lame-ass excuse but anyway
uh so phase two
was gonna take place in baltimore now
this said was never done they did kill
some people in maryland but this was
phase two apparently didn't take place
uh
the first part of phase two was they
were gonna kill a pregnant woman by
shooting her in the stomach that's okay
uh and then the next one they were gonna
kill a cop like a baltimore cop
and then at the funeral of the cop they
were going to like put a bunch of bombs
so they were going to like blow up a
bunch of other cops like at this funeral
so clearly they've like thought a lot
about janet said that they did kill some
black people
yeah i thought that there was i thought
it was kind of like all across the races
i remember like a couple
um
a couple latino women i remember uh one
or two guys that were i think
indian and yeah i remember like all kind
of all different races so i just
couldn't remember like off because there
were so many i just couldn't remember
offhand but i just remember it being
like well that's why the cops like i
said were so confused at first because
they're like well we don't think this is
racially or gender motivated because
or age motivator or whatever it's just
because it's just anybody they just
killed anybody that they could uh that
they could get to and like i said i
think sometimes that
they just kind of like set up in a spot
and then whoever kind of happened to
walk along so i think a lot of this
stuff about oh we're only targeting
white people stuff like that obviously
that wasn't true i think they were just
targeting whoever happened to
walk in the area that they were at
uh and then phase three which they did
actually seem to like they tried to do
but this was phase three was when they
were going to extort
uh all the money from the government and
they did try to do that with the letter
that they put in the ziploc bag
even though like i said even if they
really didn't want the 10 million
dollars they didn't like leave any
instructions or anything they were
basically saying i think they were
trying to like blackmail they were
saying well if you give us 10 million
dollars we'll stop killing people i
think that's what but like i said they
didn't have any details it wasn't like a
ransom where they're like hey meet me at
this xyz and like leave a briefcase full
of unmarked bills or whatever they
didn't do that they just said hey we
want 10 million dollars pretty much
uh so as i mentioned earlier they wanted
this 10 million dollars to set up a
terrorist training camp in canada
they're gonna take all these like
homeless kids from like the ymca and
stuff and they're gonna like train them
to go to war like against the united
states like i said i don't think they
were actually gonna do any of this i
just kind of feel like john muhammed was
a crazy person
and i think he came up with some of this
stuff just like
i don't know he just seemed very fantasy
prone and like that kind of crap
so
yeah
um september 2003 john muhammad uh
sentenced to death
and a month later lee malvo who was a
juvenile at the time of the crimes
got sentenced to six consecutive life
sentences without the possibility of
parole
november 2009 john muhammad was uh
executed by lethal injection
now in 2017 uh the u.s court of appeals
vacated
lee malva's three life sentences without
parole in virginia there was an appeal
uh where they were gonna do a
re-sentencing because there was a
supreme court ruling
um that said that mandatory life
sentences for juvenile criminals without
possibility of parole violated the
eighth amendment that's what it was that
i was thinking of it wasn't so much like
life sentences it was life sentence
without parole if the person was a minor
when they committed the crime like they
thought that that was uh
unconstitutional
so
some of his life sentences got uh
vacated
so there was that but
at the moment
um
lee is still in
uh
still doing multiple life sentences at
red onion state prison in virginia which
is the super max
now he will be eligible for parole in
2022 in virginia
but he also has some life sentences in
maryland which have not been affected he
has actually tried to appeal those but
so far that hasn't gone anywhere so like
i said even if he was eligible for
parole in virginia
i think maybe
i mean wouldn't he just be imprisoned in
maryland then because like i said he
they killed people across multiple
states i'm not sure how the you have to
deal with each each state that's what
i'm saying
so that law was like not but that was
just on the books in virginia
so i'm not sure how that would because
he's up for parole this year apparently
but i don't know if he'd ever get it
because he has so many life sentences
that have to do with different states
and different laws so i'm not really
sure how that would work out
now interestingly uh two in 2012
during a an interview with matt lauer of
all people
lee malvo
said that he was sexually abused by john
muhammad
which
not crazy i mean this does sound like a
grooming type of situation
so okay grammar no i'm just saying okay
boomer but okay groomer i'm just saying
that it i mean the way that is i'm not
saying that it happens maybe but it
wouldn't surprise me maybe it wouldn't
surprise me
uh actually he got married
lee malvo in uh march of 2020
so he got married in prison i don't know
what his wife's name is
now he has since
apologized for what he did
um written letters to all the victims
given interviews to the media
and one of the quotes uh that he said in
the media was
i was a monster if you look up the
definition that's what a monster is i
was a ghoul i was a thief i stole
people's lives i did someone else's
bidding just because they said so there
is no rhyme or reason or sense so
i don't know like i said he was a kid
when it happened
i don't love it i don't love the fact of
i don't i don't love the idea of him
running around
20 something years almost 20 years
yeah i don't know how old is he now
pushing 40 yeah i mean he's got to be if
he was 17 in 2002 he's about 36 30. so
yeah 37 so he's almost 40. so he's
almost 40.
yeah
that's not the same person anymore
he's out of the danger zone and they did
say that he actually seems like a
different person because and
but the thing about it is that i don't
know since he spent so much time in
prison it's like could he really be
they'd really have to work with him a
lot well
he's married right
yeah we has people that can [ __ ] help
him reintroduce himself
i guess
yeah he'd have to change his name and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that because no one's
gonna
he'd have to move somewhere else right
now and make a new identity who the [ __ ]
he is yeah just like some of those
[ __ ]
yeah cause no one's gonna give you a job
or nothing i mean he's not the same guy
no but
you know and the thing about it is like
people was like
he was a juvenile yeah
janet said i think he needs to stay in
the pen for a while yet
yeah maybe he's been 40 almost
well
maybe they should wait a little bit
longer
it just doesn't seem like it's been long
enough i don't know
mean that's really [ __ ] up yeah he was
dumb he was 17. but for christ's sake
when i was 17 i was stupid when i was 17
too but nobody's gonna talk my ass into
going around shooting random ass
innocent people
[ __ ] man come on
from a different background you should
know better yeah i know but anybody
should know better
anybody should know better any every
[ __ ] person in the world knows that
that's bad
you know what i'm saying
yeah that was him then though
this i'm just saying he's [ __ ] 17.
i can't there's a lot of [ __ ] i did at
17 i can't really relate to
yeah but you didn't do anything like
this
did you no okay i was going to say no
it's like some [ __ ] you didn't tell me
about
[ __ ] man
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about it because it's like i'm not
like i said i'm not a big fan of like
you've done this [ __ ] in his 20s i said
no let that [ __ ] rot in hell but
uh because the big difference between 20
a 17 and 22
big difference
yeah you come up real quick between that
period
he's kind of gray
i think i think i'd let him go around 40
but i keep an eye on him
yeah
it's that other dude
young guy and that dude was dead yeah
he's dead yeah
i mean he seemed he seemed like he was
the mastermind yeah he he had that dude
pumped up into thinking all kinds of
[ __ ] i don't know see we get into
this every time
like i said when we talk about like
serial killer couples and stuff like
that because usually there's like it's
kind of a similar dynamic going on
sometimes with that as well yeah and i'm
always just kind of like i always try to
think
i don't i don't want to like excuse what
they did but then i'm like well if this
person had never met that person would
they have done this [ __ ] on their own i
don't think this kid would have done
that [ __ ] i don't think it would have
occurred to him
but
maybe there's something merciful about
me i can't believe it
that's what i'm gonna say i can't
believe you're like [ __ ] arguing for
a little bit because usually it would be
the opposite is this because remember
the [ __ ] dude i'm not saying they
should fry them or nothing and i'm i'm
not saying they should never let him out
i'm just saying gay dude that was
killing all those [ __ ] people tying
to the boards and putting the glass rods
up their dicks and [ __ ] killing him
and [ __ ] and he had the dean coral dean
coral remember dean corbin the candy man
yeah candy man all right dean coraline
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up because he was
[ __ ] old enough to know but then he
had that teenage dude [ __ ] yeah going
getting victims for him what was that
guy's name yeah oh yeah that's right we
did a show about that i can't remember
it offhand but yeah i know you don't
know i think that dude did enough time
i'd let him out yeah and i mean yeah the
thing about it yeah i think i think
there are a lot of had to do that dude
was afraid of dean coral
yeah that's why i'm willing to give you
like a lot of leeway
if you got sucked into something and you
were afraid of that person and you were
afraid snowball if you [ __ ] them over
then they might kill you and [ __ ] like
that so you were like afraid to escape
and [ __ ] like that they ain't got that
dude to give up one kid which [ __ ]
made him guilty enough and feel to feel
trapped that he gave him up another one
and another one and another one
so that if he asked me that that kid was
abused
all right
and he did eventually man up and kill
dean so i wouldn't i would let him go
and i think we said that on the show
that it's like i'm not excusing what he
did when he was but one i could see how
it could happen because he was pretty
young and two he did actually kind of
redeem himself by killing him he killed
dean he did yeah i [ __ ] would have
gave him
a couple years i'd give him five or six
years but i put him in a [ __ ] some kind
of [ __ ]
mental place yeah i mean he needs some
like right counseling he was he was a
victim
really if you ask me i think he was a
victim
then i would have [ __ ] changed his
name and [ __ ] snuck him out the back
door after about five seconds i mean
you'd have to you'd have to change his
whole identity you have to move
somewhere and nobody knew him because
you wouldn't be able to have a normal
life when somebody found out who you
were no if you asked me that kid was one
of dean carl's victims all right
so but i don't i can't unders i'm not a
[ __ ] i don't have a great faith in
them in any criminal justice system it
doesn't matter the country especially
the united states it makes a lot of
mistakes and it's just [ __ ] it's a
little brutal all right it's not very
intelligent it's just kind of [ __ ]
well this is what it says so this is
what we're gonna do
we're like yeah but you know it doesn't
quite apply to this particular dude yeah
i mean everything has to be like taken
on an individual case-by-case basis
right because everybody's different
every situation is different i would
have sent that kid to a rehabilitation
thing for about [ __ ] five to ten
years
for observation and to [ __ ] chill
that dude out to get him to some [ __ ]
mental help and then [ __ ] changed his
name and reintroduced him into a society
he killed dean coral
eventually
okay like i said that kind of redeems
them and realized because at least like
i said it's not great what he did
obviously he fell in the hands of a
monster he did and [ __ ] him up and
[ __ ] lied to him and got him to do
things and
he turned him into an igor you know
and and you got a lot of people who will
[ __ ] say well that never would have
happened to me [ __ ] you weren't
there and you weren't that kid's age yes
you don't you weren't yeah you know
[ __ ] that that's
it's it was very hard to say and yeah
well like i said yeah maybe you wouldn't
have done it but you're not that person
that person's circumstances that
person's personality is yeah
might not have been quite as intelligent
as you or that kind of you know i mean
he was able to [ __ ] fall prey to that
so no i you know it's it's not a one
size fit all fits all that's why i'm not
really big into this mandatory minimum
sentencing [ __ ] and a lot of [ __ ] that
the us criminal justice system does the
judge the judges first of all judges
have to be of good good quality judges
and they have to have the leeway to make
a [ __ ] decent decision on on how to
punish somebody you know
and i think a lot of the judges their
hands are tied on how to at least in the
u.s on how to punish somebody or how to
[ __ ] find justice
you know we're like this this one is
more victim than this guy here's more
victim than perpetrator
we're gonna
put him into a place we're gonna try to
[ __ ] rehabilitate him you know i mean
that's that that's the way i'm yeah i
mean they do kind of like it does seem
like they do try like they do have like
sort of mitigating circumstances and
stuff like that but
yeah i don't really like that whole
you know mandatory sentences
because this has three strikes above him
yes yeah i don't like that because
that's like that's to one size fits all
everything and i know it's harder and i
know it takes more time and blah blah
more money probably but it's just kind
of like every situation is different you
have to approach everything well that's
what you have to do
that's what i mean have a set of
guidelines yeah don't but
don't put handcuffs on the damn judge
that's what a judge is for
is to try to figure out justice
but when you hobble the judge with these
all this mandatory minimum [ __ ] then
what do you got to judge for
what's he there for yeah that doesn't
really not be what a judge is for you
don't trust the judges well [ __ ] you
better [ __ ] change your criteria of
who a judge should be
but you know how these systems are man
they're corrupt and it's a bunch of
politics and a bunch of people [ __ ]
whining and crying and [ __ ]
everybody's fighting each other and
you're going to end up with a
dysfunctional system you know it's just
that's how it is
i don't agree with it you know but
we have to we have to recognize what it
is
it's you know
everything has to be taken on a
case-by-case basis like i said people
are saying agree we don't you agree with
yeah
yeah what you just said okay uh lion x
warrior said i still can't get my head
around why we still imprison non-violent
offenders with violent offenders yeah i
don't really get that either yeah um
yeah janet said our judicial system is
not fair man in iowa got life for third
strike for stealing bread
so yeah see that's why i don't like that
three strikes law
because like i said if you do
three minor things oh suddenly you're in
jail for life even though it's just like
stupid minor [ __ ] right non-violent
crimes honestly
i don't even know if you should do jail
time for that or
just like [ __ ] minor jail time or
fines or something one of the biggest
[ __ ] problems was the war on war on
drugs well yeah
uh i don't know if i mentioned it in
other programs but my mother was a dea
agent okay
and when dea [ __ ] was tasked with
that [ __ ] earlier they were like wait a
minute hold on no
really what's best is this [ __ ]
rehabilitation programs when the crack
epidemic hit
but not for
and biden was one of mr president now
he was one of the [ __ ] mini who
wanted to [ __ ] crack down with the
three strikes you're out thing biden did
the three strikes throughout thing and
and cracking down on these drugs
and when they cracked down on the
[ __ ] drugs back in the 80s
all it did was just create drug cartels
and offenders that were willing to kill
cops
over
a damn near worthless drug
but they made that work they made that
worthless drug into gold
but then rich people got richer on it
and drug cartels came which and then the
cops got [ __ ] rich on it and the
state got rich on it fighting it so it
makes you wonder did they know what they
were doing i think i kind of think they
did i think they said we're going to
make a whole new industry out of this
dumbasses because they didn't give a
[ __ ] about us
they'll kill get you killed in a [ __ ]
crossfire between [ __ ] drug cartels
or you're a cop and you're getting shot
over because some dude shoots you
because he doesn't want to go to jail
for 50 years for having a bag of little
white [ __ ] in his [ __ ] pocket
it's just [ __ ] stupid stupid
and drug prohibition is not american
it's not american
you go back and look in the history of
the 1800s man they had what was called
the right to bliss
they eat
cowboys and all these guys from the old
west as american and [ __ ] as mom
apple pie and chevrolet the cowboys and
[ __ ] were doing cocaine
and and morphine
and weed and [ __ ]
booze they they did all that there
wasn't anything again there wasn't any
laws against that
now you can say well you can't have all
these high people driving cars well we
got a laws against that drunk driving
and [ __ ] driving under the influence
you could you can
legislate that
but as soon as you start with all these
[ __ ]
we're gonna give you [ __ ] life
sentence for [ __ ] having heroin and
[ __ ] well all of a sudden these dudes
are willing to kill over it and the
[ __ ] price of heroin goes to the roof
you're gonna make [ __ ]
empires built on heroin and [ __ ] it's
dumb dumb dumb dumb
bad
should have made that [ __ ] a misdemeanor
and all the money gets sucked out of it
because i said it goes away i've always
been a big advocate of uh
or at least decriminalizing all drugs
yeah and prostitution decriminalize and
regulate that will get rid of a lot of
uh problems
because you no longer have
that's the thing too is like drug
dealers because their business is uh
illegal like if they have a beef with
like some other drug dealer then they're
gonna handle that uh extra judiciously
let's call it that as soon as it's not
that illegal or the penalties aren't
that high the price of their of their
product starts plummeting
which means and then the time that they
have to serve for for selling it [ __ ]
goes down
so then all of a sudden there's no
impetus to shoot one another
yeah because it's not worth it it's not
really worth it like i said you don't
see people shooting each other over
[ __ ] cigarettes or vapes or exact
booze exactly because there's there's
there you're not gonna do any time over
it and there's not any money involved in
it so nobody gives a [ __ ] and it just
it becomes a non-issue
if you make it an issue it becomes an
issue but i think they made it an issue
because they wanted to become an issue
because they wanted to make money with
it
you know
just like
it wouldn't surprise me if our ruling
classes heavily invested in it
you know
make a lot of money mexico's ruling
class is
so
leads me to believe that america's
ruling glass is heavily invested in the
drug cartels
why not make black funding and i bet you
the government is they've always said
the cia makes a [ __ ] ton of money on it
wouldn't surprise me
if it ever came out the [ __ ] cia was
[ __ ] running all these drugs and [ __ ]
making all kinds of money black funding
to fund their projects and then they
pocketed to buy mansions and
pools and [ __ ] if they ever came out i'd
be like yeah it wouldn't surprise me
wouldn't surprise me at all because
other countries are doing that
yeah
yeah
murder hornet returns federal has almost
got me today in mexico it's cause you're
going through the [ __ ] customs
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] and you don't
you're not carrying anything but you're
making them thinking that you're
carrying a thing because you go through
their [ __ ] drop
all right
leave them alone stop [ __ ] with them
people
yeah yeah the [ __ ] mexican cops are
gonna lock his ass up for being drunk
going through [ __ ] customs
and leave him hookers alone man
[ __ ] sends me [ __ ] clips
through his phone i think i'm gonna [ __ ]
this one some [ __ ] pretty ass mexican
girl they're booty up in the air sitting
in the front [ __ ] waiting like asking
you for his opinion on like yeah he
asked me which one which one he asked me
to choose one for him did you do you do
it a long time ago
pretty ass mexican girl with her booty
up in the air in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
front window of the place he's like
should i should i go ahead and hit this
one and look at him yeah yeah go ahead
[Laughter]
and he's in mexico
damn
he needs me here in florida to tell him
which one of these mexican hookers the
[ __ ] i can't understand well he wants
your opinion what's my opinion which one
you trust your tastes just my face yeah
that's ridiculous yeah dudes are
ridiculous dudes are ridiculous i think
it's just ridiculous and i'm on the i'm
on the receiving end of it
[Laughter]
it is ridiculous yeah
yeah
all right so uh we've been going three
hours yeah i'll make us something to eat
ooh we're making food yeah yeah and i
got some chicken marinade oh that's
right and would you want some of that uh
make uh get some indian rice going okay
you hungry yeah and then i'll make
[ __ ] chicken tandoori because i got
that tandoor chicken sitting back there
[ __ ]
it's uh
marinating all right that sounds good
actually yeah it's just thighs that's
all i got that's my favorite part okay
all right everybody knows i like thighs
on the chicken well the uh
the drumsticks might be thawed but they
haven't really been marinated i could
just cover them in marinade and [ __ ]
cook those in the same way i mean either
way like oh good i mean thighs are good
legs are good all right it's good all
right
all right so thanks everybody for
dropping by this evening this was
actually a pretty good shot i didn't get
too [ __ ] up so i was actually able to
tammy says a really good show tonight
yeah okay thank you thank you tabby kept
most of my notes on yeah on point which
is good
uh so yeah hopefully you guys had a good
time we will see you guys on friday
night for the sidetrack show where we're
just gonna drink and talk about what the
[ __ ] ever we feel like uh so thanks for
dropping by have a good
rest of your night have a good day
tomorrow and we will see you guys on
friday evening
bye